you
[Music]
can
[Music]
perfect perfect
[Music]
what's up guys how's your [ __ ]
day going awesome custard off the bat
how's your day going i am thomas
dopaziola whatever you want to call me
welcome back to the dope as usual
podcast we're here to talk about life
problems drugs accomplishments and
everything in between today's guest is
someone you've been asking for
non-stop even though they're here all
the time but we figured it out marty
o'neil drastic graphics what's up
guys uh we finally figured it out
all the comments have marty is a guest
but
he is on the show
now i understand
at the table's completely different we
figured out how he can run the tape run
the show with one hand yeah and then
focus on the camera over here so here we
go guys um
what's up marty
man [ __ ] we've been running around all
day making moves took us man we've been
doing a lot we just came and sat down
and i know
we've been doing a bunch of stuff today
manufacturing a bunch of weird fun stuff
behind the scenes stuff
so
you have no idea what i'm gonna ask you
i have no notes and i'm just gonna start
everyone knows where you're from you're
from buffalo
this episode guys is going to be
a little different because i don't want
to ask you everything
because we still have years of podcasts
left i want to i want to i'm going gonna
do this
and just skip scenes yep because i know
certain things you've told me we've
never elaborated on
ready
where are you from marty
saw buffalo new york south buffalo new
york so i was growing up in the early
90s at buffalo it was [ __ ] awesome
yeah yeah yeah it was great
what the [ __ ] all our conversations wait
what do you what do you mean
yeah from my childhood like i always say
oh yeah so it was cool i loved my
childhood was great compared to like all
my friends i ended up growing up with
like that's the one thing i always
noticed like
from 0 to 15 on those formative years
was peaceful in my life like it was
simple it was like i said me kicking a
[ __ ] ball around by myself like only
child the 80s like it was just old
school yeah like roaming around the
neighborhood and [ __ ] it was wholesome
simple
you know i didn't have compared to what
other kids go through at that young age
yeah in
the grand scheme of things i had it very
very very good the homeward bound
childhood like just the nice
i have animals and you know my mom and
dad are together there's like some
sandlot [ __ ] that's great yeah that's
awesome i always watch the sound like
wow these guys have a house in their own
room and they play bass baseball and eat
hot dogs in july like yeah
what like i was always like my parents
were hippies though like prior to that
they were a little bit older
your dad is was a hippie
full-blown full-blown hippie yes your
mom also yes i didn't know that about
you yeah yeah full
full-blown full-blown hippies yeah but
my dad was like a musician too so it was
even like part of his business hippie
he didn't have a business side to him
whatsoever he was a musician what did he
do for work musician he taught guitar
and he gigged out oh that's we had the
studio upstairs yeah oh
really yeah yeah i didn't know that yeah
so hit and miss with checks
he was consistent he's he's a legend
he's in the after he passed i accepted
his induction into the buffalo music
hall of fame
so
yeah it was a big deal oh wow
yeah his his circle was like you know
the music scene like legendary no [ __ ]
yeah
what your dad just played guitar right
yep and he sang but he was in a couple
big bands like the night i was born he
was gigging out
red i was born and you keep saying
gigging out in the bay that means you're
on ecstasy
so that's why i'm like uh what do you
mean he's gigging out no in the 80s that
should've meant you're playing at a bar
you know he's really yeah
i didn't know that man i did out of all
the times you talked about your dad you
never i never know that yeah yeah like
they were that badass they were given
updates at the bar as like
while i was being being boys like how is
he a boy yeah exactly so i would have
people random people in buffalo come up
to me like how are you in the ball
yeah
that's cool man yeah so now i see why
he's like
oh you're a rapper
i get it he was just like
following my footsteps more he probably
would have appreciated that i get it
everybody has their own path i
understand also if he wasn't pushing
music on you at a young age before he
started liking rap that's his fault
he was he was
were you absorbing it no no he didn't
like like not really i mean i remember
him trying to teach me music and [ __ ]
not so much like i love it i had i had
all the [ __ ] you talking about i had the
uh paul simon vinyl the beatles vinyl
laying around i remember all that
five six years old but i mean i loved it
it was cool but then i remember the
first time i ever heard it can nobody
take my pride
the puffy version as soon as i heard
that
it was over i was obsessed
really yeah i was like seven eight years
old
puffy mace biggie
who are you hanging out with as a kid
there's like regular kids around your
neighborhood
yeah because i played you know
neighborhood kids sports kids were they
influencing your music too
no i was it had they had my friends and
my music had completely we moved around
a lot too so by the time i was uh
i don't know six we lived in a bunch of
different places so i had like
different friends but my friends weren't
really super tied into like my music
until i was telling you like my brother
got adopted he was i was like 11 he was
like nine and then we were both as
equally obsessed with hip-hop
so you're around seven or eight you
discover hip-hop you're an only child
your mom and dad are hippies
and then they
adopt your brother well my my aunt and
uncle did your aunt your mom your dad's
sister adopted some kid
and then eventually when he was like oh
we can't handle this kid you dobby no no
right away they just kind of paired us
up off the bat oh and eventually just
like you guys take care of he loves
marty well they kept having it didn't
necessarily go smoothly you know after
years they were having fallen outs and
he ended up just kind of living in my
house for a long time at what age
he was in high school still so probably
like he was probably 15. you're 17-ish
yeah when you guys are just every day
together yeah the whole time we were
every day together because as soon as he
moved in even like
i would just live at his house the whole
summer
i'd be at his house the whole summer i'd
be doing summer school that i worked
downtown i was like we had delaware park
right there like i was telling you about
directly next door we used to walk there
every day
yeah no like we people looked at us
weird because we really called each
other brothers like we would introduce
each other like that but it was like on
some white man can't jump [ __ ] like yeah
brothers people wouldn't understand me
so why is this new world over here yeah
the people that knew knew me knew what
it was like yeah i respected that even
my whole school understood because like
i said my uncle that was his like foster
father was my basketball coach so that
even tied it in even deeper he'd send us
the basketball game he played basketball
too
my brother yeah yeah yeah yeah you know
light
light light yeah so you're the
basketball so yeah i was obsessed
so we'd be at basketball camp all day
we'd be at delaware park all day and
then at night it's us out on the lowered
rim we never one time played a game that
didn't end in a fight both of you guys
fighting each other every single time
we'd play one-on-one would no matter
what that company and it would just be
power dunking and just like you know
power on the low rims the low rims on
that seven eight street yeah that's cool
that was that was summers though we were
just playing that was the great thing
about like my adolescence that really
kept me under trouble was basketball i
was [ __ ] obsessed so i was just out
there setting up the sundown so you guys
are always fighting no matter what
yeah yeah and i was telling you there
was a couple times like he had a lot of
[ __ ] issues i mean this kid was
i told you i'm gonna put all this
business out there yeah you don't have
to say his name don't put all his stuff
out but i was talking about like what
affects a kid at a super young age and
it's like that's why you guys adopted
situations like yeah i mean you get born
into a messed up family that family just
leaves you with somebody who you know
abuses you you end up in the system and
by the time you're seven eight years old
your [ __ ] brain wiring is all [ __ ]
yeah you didn't get the opportunity to
develop properly i i
was highly aware that how different we
were and like how just unfair it was to
him because like we played basketball
he'd take off his shirts he'd have
[ __ ] scars on his back and [ __ ]
like
i could just he was so young
and as the years went on i could just
just tell like how deep that pain is
when your mom leaves you
like that
and it would come out like as we'd get a
little bit older sometimes he'd get
drunk and [ __ ] and it would come out
he'd start [ __ ] talking about it but
other than that he'd never talk about it
oh he just like joked
it was like the honeydew we only yeah
just made light of it at everything got
it well you said your dad's funeral you
guys were cracking jokes but that's only
because it's all we did
i get it it really was like that i mean
especially in situations like that so
your dad [ __ ] with them too
yeah my dad actually liked him a lot
you know like they they related they
related a weird
relationship just he's literally just
getting passed to families and even
while he was within while he like he was
like being fostered he came in he's
being fostered 9 10 11. he gets you know
put into a different school all this
like there were still times where he got
kicked out and he went back in the
system
like when i was when i was playing
college basketball he got kicked out for
like threatening my aunt or some [ __ ]
went back in the system went to a house
got kicked out of that house and then
ended up deep on the [ __ ] east side
on glenwood and box or some [ __ ] delavan
over there i remember going over there i
brought i remember i brought him my
dream cast
going over there in the snow him like
he's not even supposed to be going
running out happening in my car like it
was [ __ ] weird he's living with a
whole other family and [ __ ] but then he
grew up with you now he's with another
family that's weird because there's
families that'll have foster kids just
for the chat yeah you have some elderly
now you're just running the [ __ ] east
side on free roam
and it's [ __ ] deadly over there so he
was over there and then i mean that's
where he was originally started at
then he came back and he was like
staying in my mom's basement for a long
time and we were you know and but then
he started getting into robberies and
[ __ ] and yeah i wasn't knowing about it
until i saw him on the news oh
whack yeah
so he started just like oh what a bummer
hanging out with some kids that i i knew
about but i didn't know
i hung out with dudes that were doing
[ __ ] but they weren't [ __ ] overt
scumbags these kids were [ __ ]
scumbags
but
he felt like his my aunt and uncle moved
out to like the suburbs like the legit
suburbs they built a house moved away
from delaware park and now he's the only
black kid out in a white neighborhood
and he like
got found a couple other ghetto ass kids
and then they went ended up robbing a
bank and robbing a couple other things
they didn't get caught that's why you
said the day my brother got bank robbery
charged that's the same brother all of
the stories you told me is the same guy
this is this is the only dude i grew up
with like that
[ __ ] yeah so he ended up doing three
years and then and while you're doing
that you're doing music and going to
school but yeah that like when he went
to prison i had just met april i was on
my like
was that my biggest peak of like my
music my hottest [ __ ] point so when
he went into prison you already had that
song on the radio and [ __ ] yes
i was really really getting deep into it
and he was there with me every single
step of the way we were there he was
there from way before day one
all the [ __ ] i was writing about was it
was like your uncle john like when you
were telling that story it was exactly
like that but i was older than him got
you
yeah together all day yeah yeah i mean
like we shared a bed he slept on the
floor he slept like
we slept in the attic together
when he'd get his bike stolen i was i'd
[ __ ] get it back for him that type of
[ __ ]
damn
i i totally understand the relationship
now yeah so
you he goes to prison you get out you
already have a baby
he went in
when he went in it was looking like i
was going to be the one going in
just based on
where i was at in life i was just doing
stupid [ __ ] i was on some just get rich
or die trying i was just on some like
it's going to take i don't know like
what it's gonna take to make it but i'm
willing to do whatever the [ __ ] it takes
at this point i was at a real fork
really at that juncture in my life like
no you know undeniably me and him were
not me i never i was always a positive
role model in his life i always looked
at myself as a positive role model for
him like his bigger brother but he knew
what i was i was getting wrapped up in
all kinds of [ __ ] outside of my life
with him too
especially when i started really going
ham with the music
and then when he went down like my dad
was dying we thought he was gonna die at
that point it was one of those times i
thought jamal was gonna go for like 15
years
and it was just like it was so [ __ ]
horrible it was really really really
horrible because there was like he sat
downtown for a year before we even knew
it was going to happen
and then they sentenced them luckily he
was
under 18. oh so they they didn't but
they weren't going to they no they were
trying to try him
my uncle pulled strings and
because he's like and then finesse that
[ __ ]
good but i mean it was [ __ ] horrible
but while he was in there
by the time he could when he went in i
was [ __ ] just like out there
basically i didn't have i only had like
potential going on but didn't look great
i just graduated high school i mean i
had job and [ __ ] but
i was doing [ __ ] that definitely could
have got me arrested on the regular
and then um by the time he came out i
had the 300 seat i had a house i had a
kid that's that era i
threw him a [ __ ] the ipad touch when
he came out he didn't know what the [ __ ]
it was that and it was like that and we
were hanging out at my house nice and we
had about a year where it was awesome
he's back in the studio with me every
day now i'm almost i'm getting like
record deals and [ __ ] now
i'm making a real push now it's no
longer like i'm out of b i'm not working
outside of buffalo now when he gets back
the the songs i had a stretch where
i was going into the studio and every
time it was for
an executive
meaning i'm going back and forth with
these [ __ ] fools and they're saying
just give me this just give me that just
give me this just give me that
and he was there for every session like
if you follow griselda all those studios
you see them in the same ones you're in
a lot of them yeah yeah you always sound
like it's crazy seeing these griselda
posts man like that's the studio i was
recording in yeah because i know when i
first brought up grazel do you go
from buffalo griselda i go they're hard
he goes yeah but they're real gangsters
he's like i didn't want to chill there
no more because i was like oh these
fools are on some serious [ __ ]
well if you're if you know buffalo when
i'm about to say some legendary [ __ ]
there was a time i've been in every
studio in buffalo anybody who was doing
music in buffalo at that time i had
networked with at some point i sat with
dj shea in the buff city records
and he sat there and listened to my
music and was talking about my beats and
you know he just passed away he was the
that's the guy you're talking about he
gets dj in buffalo he's the conduit to a
lot of this yeah as far as i think so
i'm not sure but i think so
he's responsible for a lot of this stuff
that you see this legendary [ __ ] this
never before seen [ __ ] coming out of
buffalo that might not seem big to
people but it inspires a whole goddamn
city yeah it was a small city not even a
small city like a poor city when you
have a poor small city that doesn't have
a lot of jobs and opportunity and you
have a big sports team like cleveland
when lebron's there like pittsburgh when
the steelers are winning the super bowl
it makes the vibe of the city different
because it gives hope it gives that's
true pride
a hundred percent look at oakland when
the oakland raiders are killing it
everyone's outside [ __ ] it
everyone's like
yeah there's life here like it's
different everybody has a little more
pep and [ __ ] like yeah the old jackets
come out of the starter jacket yeah it's
just uh yeah it's the pride thing when i
was there i was the opposite of that it
was like the like reverse of like oh
everything's oh oh we always [ __ ]
lose everything's oh there's it's always
grey clouds out it's uh it was like it
felt like that
more that's buffalo
that's what it was when i was i mean
because even if you grew up in la and
you grew up in the worst part of la you
can even you can always look and be like
this person did it that person did it
yeah there's nothing
ten minutes from here yeah like
yeah that had never said we had rick
james like there was nobody there was no
and there's no direct opportunity and a
lot of it was pre-internet or before i
was you're able to really like establish
connections that's why kids look up a
trap trap stars like well he's making it
he's got a [ __ ] brand new s-s-class
he broke his house yeah i'm struggling
not struggling and of course you're
gonna look at that guy oh he's got a
super pretty girl with them oh all the
other girl
it's the most tempting thing ever like
what does he do just selling stuff
that's it and then you get into like oh
he's pop fools he's robbing people oh
everything that comes with that
everything like you can't sell coke
without shooting somebody it just
doesn't work unless you're you're a
high-end dude in l.a selling sacks to
these people at [ __ ] nightclubs
it doesn't work you have to be willing
to make me think of the dude the the
colombian dude and paid in full when he
said that
uh uh lu lulu yeah
yeah see this he's a lulu got himself
yeah he knows what's up too he even got
popped in that nice ass apartment
building
great movie watch peyton full sorry dj
shay let's go back
first time in existence i remembered
what we were talking about yeah
you said i was about to say some
legendary [ __ ] dj shake go
yeah i mean i sat with him we listened
to my music all that and even in that
moment that was like
oh man i could do the math on it it was
like probably 2005 2006 i was aware of
like benny back then
he had already been out he had been
he was already i brought him up you said
all these guys been around yeah yeah you
told me yeah but that's the important
part to it because it's not like they
just popped off there's
years of real work and they did it
independently granted they became well
known when they signed with eminem and
jay-z and all this other [ __ ] but that
is an independent record label that came
deep out of the streets and is flooding
the mainstream right now and they're
keeping it pretty i mean super authentic
to their own sound that's what i love
about it too is they have their own
sound you can be like oh it sounds like
wu-tang that's kind of a really super
generalized statement because it sounds
like griselda they have their own i
don't think they sound like anybody else
i heard
i mean yeah it's the east coast i hear
that in a lot of people
but that's the accent we're not looking
for the accent that's authenticity it's
the sound like yeah like i told you go i
don't know who these guys are but you
ever heard of and you go
from buffalo uh-huh i don't [ __ ] know
yeah yeah when i first i heard i go who
the [ __ ] is this
like i said gangsta gangster ass lyrics
but are good jack of [ __ ] i'm all over
it i'm all over it man i loved it that
[ __ ] gets me fired up i know every time
you pull up i'm like yo marty's in that
crazy move bumping right every time
and it opens the door oh [ __ ] show
joe oh [ __ ]
every time
i can hear you every time that's
hilarious um
so you're in buffalo you come out or
your brother gets out of jail
you have one year of everything going
good all your shit's happening and then
you have to get into it but you guys had
it fallen out yeah yeah so
it was when i got my record deal with dj
ski
so i was using this service called blaze
track it's still around but it's
different now it's owned by different
people than originally and blaze track
was the first really let me make
connections
it said put together a press kit you pay
for the credits and you send it directly
to the record exec and they give you a
video response to your thing
so that was my [ __ ] i made
hundreds of submissions i spent
thousands of dollars on blaze track
but it paid off in the sense that blaze
track noticed blaze track made me a
blaze track pro eventually i've
spun the tables around
and i ended up getting this i kind of
became like the poster boy for blaze
track with this deal i got with dj skee
wow and then that
so when that happened i remember it was
me jamal my boy malachi malakai had
gotten his apartment maokai we were
talking about the
cultures and like in in lack of one and
[ __ ] where i'm from you've got the
yebenese community you got your white
people you got your black people you got
your puerto ricans
so malachi was um
yemen half japanese
but wild boy like
wild but i knew him since he was super
young
when jamal went to jail
i bumped into him and he's like
basically like bro let me like
i want to do music like and me and him
just like while jamal was in prison me
and him because he became like jamel so
when jamal came out of prison it was the
three of us
got you i had known him since he was a
kid we had played basketball in bath
park for years i did like his you know i
knew malachi and i respected his passion
he came from [ __ ] up circumstances too
parents selling drugs growing up him
being involved all that type of [ __ ]
robberies all that type of [ __ ]
so
10 minutes yeah it's been oh [ __ ] it's
25 yeah it's been passed but we yeah
it's us we're gonna talk for hours
but anyway the three of us became really
close and they started to kind of thank
you sir
make their own little relationship
and malachi got you know his girl had an
apartment or whatever and i remember
we're hanging out over there and jamal's
like bro this is real you got a [ __ ]
record deal
but he wanted me to basically leave
april and
ariana and the three of us go move out
to [ __ ] california he's like because
he had a job he didn't have any
responsibility my uncle hooked him up
with the job when he got out so he
didn't have any bills he was making
money a little i mean when i say making
money he was making the money you make
when you have a job and don't have bills
got you and my uncle was a professional
accountant so when he got out he had his
[ __ ] together for him good
she wanted you to leave april and your
baby basically just so you guys can go
pursue the music yeah
on somehow you know and i mean you know
so that's what i said
and he
he got real [ __ ] offended because he
didn't like you know mind you i had just
gotten married he's my best man both
these fools are my best men at my
wedding
uh
you know it was out for you to get
married
mm-hmm oh he's my best man
yeah and
uh sorry
yeah so
it's out of that pouch you got
no i got different weed that's different
sorry for the delay marty's literally
staring at his joints
what is this
no that's fire
uh he was your best man yeah you got
anywhere there was no there was no
tension he didn't
like april got along there was nothing
weird
something weird happened in his mind
where he really started resenting me
like having a family like i can't just
effortlessly smoke blunts all throughout
the house like one might i can't just go
to california like one might and he
starts like
looking at me like this [ __ ]
you know like
meanwhile [ __ ] out of here this is my
goddamn life and your child and i'm on
it by the way i'm the only one with this
[ __ ] going on let's not like i'm at this
i'm the only one at the steering wheel
this operation these fours are tagging
along
but it's your brother so you're gonna
bring him along forever
i get it i get it he's at every studio
session
he's at he's at everything so
i remember we were hanging out one time
during this like little period it was
the first time i ever listened to a
podcast with him i put on rogan and diaz
while we were playing uh
we were playing like 2k to live or
whatever we were playing and it was all
good and then like april came home it
was late
and he
started acting real [ __ ] weird
on some
nah i've got something to tell you but
i'm not gonna take
you started doing that type of [ __ ] to
you or her to both of us
like i got something to tell you about
her
just like started acting real weird out
of [ __ ] nowhere
and i was like it's the last time i ever
saw him no yeah this is the last time i
ever thought
so brother yeah
so i was like an hour and he's like he
gets up to leave and i like slap him up
i'm like the [ __ ] wrong with you
you're acting real [ __ ] weird
and he just left
and uh
it like we but we had like a it was like
a falling out as like it was went from
us just chilling to us having a weird
falling out and him
leaving in
real quick like it's the last time you
saw your brother yeah
so what the [ __ ] i mean it goes on
so like and it's weird i know it sounds
weird but that's literally what happened
so
he
he basically like starts spreading all
these like really really like horrific
rumors i guess you would say but within
my like family the [ __ ] that's like not
you guys yeah just not even like out of
not even maybe he's just true he's like
yo the only person that's with me now
has a family that i never had and now
he's gone he doesn't
you gotta think none of my friends even
know what a functional family looks like
i get it but from his perspective he
just got out of prison he's never had a
family you're the only family he knows
and now your family has a family
and now he's secondary to that yeah for
sure he just got upset i get it remember
he's probably still young in his head
yeah his name is still yeah he's
probably 20 fresh out of prison he was
in grown man's prison yeah fresh out of
prison what happened in there all we
ever did was really joke about it but
it started to get really tense and we
were on bad terms for like a week we
didn't see each other we didn't really
talk it was tense that happened that
fast yeah but then my daughter's
birthday party came rolling around
first birthday fourth birthday
oh that's right he was in jail for three
years okay
she's turning four she calls him uncle
mel like those are uncle
i go to walmart to get the birthday cake
some other [ __ ] that we need walmart's
like 10 minutes away
when i get to walmart i get a call from
april yo jamal and malakai just showed
up here
i'm like why the [ __ ] i called jamal no
answer i called malachi i'm like i know
what the [ __ ] you boys are doing there
but we haven't even talked like obvious
it was to the point that i was like
obviously don't come to this [ __ ]
party right now we there was like big
tension we need to [ __ ] talk
don't be there when i come back i'm
coming back right now
hung up
when i get back there from walmart 10
minutes later i'm like getting the cake
and cashing out and then i leave and i
fly home the cops are there
the cops are at your house yes birthday
party yes
and this is in the suburbs we had moved
on they got their fast then they got
their fastest [ __ ] best because
i told you we moved to new jersey we
moved back to new jersey we lived in my
mom's house for a while and then we
moved out for a year to a nice house on
lake and that's where you were that's
where we were
cops showed up yes
and because he had this whole [ __ ]
big meltdown he's pouring beers over
everybody's face having a [ __ ]
threatening all my
girls at the party and she's just a
four-year-old's birthday party
he just came in and [ __ ] like blew
the party up basically to the point that
the neighbors or somebody called the
cops on him and then got the [ __ ] out
before i even got back
that's [ __ ] up and then after that
happened that caused the whole ripple
effect of issues within my family
and then
super high tension in the air to the
point that it was [ __ ] super high
attention in the air for
up until basically me moving to
california
bro
you just had super high tension in the
air to the point where it was super high
attention you're high as [ __ ] right now
try to emphasize i get it so you guys
are basically like so one of us got to
kill each other that's how i could i
just knew he was [ __ ] crazy basically
at that time he's your brother you know
what he's capable of yeah yeah and he's
more mad at you and you're his brother
yeah i'm mad in the sense of like this
[ __ ] how dare you are you like
no
of all days
and and my other boys wrapped up on his
side of the [ __ ] too malik yeah so
and like i said i was already falling
back from all my friends at that point i
was getting deep into rogan i was
getting really serious about music to
the point that i didn't want to be
helping out a bunch of other people with
it i was focused on myself i wasn't
bringing a thousand people to the studio
i wasn't
growing up yeah i was growing up i had a
family yeah
you have a [ __ ] kid in a whole life
yeah exactly you yeah
you have four friends at that point yeah
you dial it back by 90 mm-hmm i can hang
it with three people it went yeah but at
that i mean that was my closest inner
circle
uh
and it just it kind of put me in a dark
place for a while it [ __ ] it really
did but at the same time
you're saying like in terms of
with him oh for sure did you because you
moved away how much that how long after
so
birthday party beer pouring on imagine
this
birthday party is
her birthday is june 25th
i fly out to california for the first
time september 11th
so i flew out to california for the
first time
two months after this happened
you guys haven't talked after that no
just tension in the air
i talked to the kid malachi and what
happened what did he say
so i gotta know bro i never what do you
mean like what did you say like yo what
the [ __ ] is wrong with these you guys
showing up at the party and crashing it
he didn't have an excuse i didn't i
hadn't talked to him i never told him
you didn't you ever talked to malachi
oh yeah with that yeah basically like i
didn't know i was going to go like that
i didn't think he was going to do that
he just he just got pissed
but come fight me then if you want to
just come [ __ ] fight me then if you
just want like oh it was like that like
he didn't know how to these
[ __ ] are immature as [ __ ] they
don't know what the [ __ ] hold on you
guys are also kids at the time yeah you
guys are now in your 30s all of you and
the way i grew up i cut like i would cut
you out of my life very very quickly i
love doing that i love going i'll never
talk to you again because it makes me go
i'm not gonna waste any more time i know
what kind of person you are now thank
god i didn't do this for three more
years yeah but i mean i didn't want to
do that at all of course that's your
[ __ ] brother and best friend yeah and
i didn't foresee it and it was over it
was literally over nothing except you
didn't do anything yeah you just live in
your life i was pushing forward with
life that's it you're still hanging out
with the guys just not as much yeah
some people get upset at that man
apparently so i mean i would i really
hope that they think different now
because
because i didn't do anything i'm [ __ ]
sorry uh if you know we got a kid in the
house and we're not smoking hella blunts
in here yeah that's it so [ __ ] sorry
that was like basically what it was
so sorry if you feel like we're not
[ __ ] gangsters or some [ __ ] i don't
know what the [ __ ] to tell you
that sucks man but so you guys had a
falling out you moved to california so
i said i went to cal i did 10 days in
cali the california campaign thing right
yes
so so i think have we talked we talked
about this a little bit on the podcast
did we i don't remember yeah we talked
about it on like episode two
so the quick first [ __ ] was epic you
went to california because you were
meeting dj it relates to our last
episode so we remember goofy from the
[ __ ] last episode we did right yeah
that guy goofy that stuff he stole the
weed when he stole that weed he came out
to the west coast
and linked you and linked me
inadvertently yeah the next call i got
with him he's all [ __ ] goofy i hadn't
talked to him he's leaving me voicemails
blowing me up
i'm with snoop snoop can't finish my
joints that's not true i'm with [ __ ]
dr dre i'm in the studio
and at first i'm like all right bro you
owe me two zips
some time had passed he walked who for
the zips my boy which one
the one the crazy [ __ ] yes okay well i
mean he's your standard street dude
crazy i mean way you told me you can't
really say everything but it's a crazy
[ __ ] yeah
yeah
regular crazy you're walking for some
zips i mean jesus yeah for sure and it's
not just him it's his cousins oh
anyway i end up getting back on the
phone with this kid and it was all
[ __ ] goofy ass nonsense but he did
end up linking me with a kid who worked
at interscope records who legitimately
was dr dre's intern so i made that
connection through that and then cut
goofy the [ __ ] back off again forever
yeah so thanks man thanks for those two
zips i paid for you where is this
repaint this is repaying me
so uh
stayed in touch with him for a while
like you said earlier people with music
i'm [ __ ] pitching myself to this kid
he's younger than me he's from texas
he's interning out there i'm getting him
on the phone he's answering i'm just
going in on him rapping at him and [ __ ]
on the phone yes oh [ __ ] marty so that
uh you're the guy with the oversized
pants pulling mixtapes out the oversized
pants
yeah yeah
yeah no 30 yeah if it's 30 wide
so i signed the deal with dj ski
my boys had to like
a lot of a lot of my boys in lack wanted
through a little like concert right
before i left inadvertently and it felt
like a going-away party kind of
it felt like a college reunion like
everybody in the town knew what was
going on they're all pat me on the
[ __ ] back and [ __ ] i was like okay
it's happening
no
no me and him are just at odds over
[ __ ] oh man that's such a sad [ __ ]
he would have been too of course and
that'd be the most alt the ultimate like
yeah that was like i was saying the only
celebrated by yourself in your head
basically
i mean it's me and april we're a team at
this point i'm talking about with your
homies that were there before
i mean i still had a lot of other ones
though but he was just the closest by
far any of my close friends would have
looked at jamal like oh he's as close as
[ __ ] by far because i knew when we
were together with little kids
but
anyway so september 11th i fly out
and now mind you i'm staying with this
kid chris this is a funny story in and
of itself first my
10-day stint out here in la i've never
been out here before
i fly out september 11th i land he had
gotten funny prior bro i don't know if
you're going to be able to do the
landlord this he'd start you know
just throwing me off my goddamn game a
little bit i'm like [ __ ] that i'm coming
be there [ __ ] period yeah so he we did
we got there he's cool he picks me up
his girl's with him
now this girl right away i can tell
she's weird she starts right away going
in with the oh you're from buffalo you
must know all about the mafia and all
about the illuminati and what yeah like
what the [ __ ] does that mean
like are you from merced you know to
cook crack right
i don't know a goddamn thing
i mean i'm aware that that's a thing but
i'm not i don't know i don't [ __ ]
know anything about you
going down this whole conspiracy theory
route
as we're driving in from lax meanwhile
oh man you got a jersey on listen to
conspiracy theories i'm like looking
around at la for the first time like oh
my god
this is real i'm here she's like
happened and then i'm seeing i remember
there's like a fire off in the distance
i'm like there's a [ __ ] fire going on
over there yeah yeah no that's normal
there's just smoke billowing over the
hills that's fine
that's a trip though you
coming out here to meet dj skee to meet
all these people going this is my first
eyes on california yeah it was surreal
so when you flew in i know you were
staring out the window you were that guy
oh i was on a goddamn mission oh my god
i missed i almost missed those days
because i was just when you're all
potential you're like i got nothing but
a [ __ ] ton of potential and hard work
like i'm
that's you right now you know that right
nothing's changed [ __ ]
everything you kept saying like you mean
this morning that's funny
it's a different field so just this this
little chapter is funny so
we start he's driving me around now he
starts dropping this [ __ ] so he drops
her off at we go to bel air the first
place we go is bel-air okay
i'm like
fresh prince is my reference i already
knew
he drops her off he's like oh she's a
homeopathic uh healer she gets out
there's this giant massive gate she
whatever we go
down and now we go to eat in west
hollywood i don't know what hollywood is
the waiter walks up to us without a
shirt on
oh you went to boys town i don't [ __ ]
yeah it's west hollywood's like a
like there's like a gay area i told you
with my uncle uh yeah it's wild it was
fun but it was wild so like we ate there
then we went and picked her back up and
then we like went drop her off at
another place like another appointment
so she's a hooker coming to find out i'm
not even sure if this [ __ ] fool's
aware of this or not she's a he's a yeah
so yes
his girlfriend yes he doesn't realize i
don't i don't think he does [ __ ]
hooker i don't think he does he thinks
she's just like her his girlfriend
homeopathic healer did she bring a bag
does she bring
tools
a table i don't anything
there was no
[ __ ] folding table with her we were
in a challenger the first thing you do
is go on a home run yes in california
like a gta mission love it i love it
drop the hoe off to get to your next rap
battle
that's you
so then on the way home we pick up our
friend and this [ __ ] is this [ __ ] is
overtly like i can tell something's
wrong with this bit this [ __ ] next to
me now
so we drive back now we they're in
bourbon oh do you
25
three or twenty four
twenty five maybe i don't remember where
the year was dragged around l.a it was
fine it was amazing i was in awe i'm
just saying with the hookers yes i
didn't realize at first
we're not understanding he's right this
uh this is this isn't goofy at this this
is i mean he is this kid chris is goofy
as [ __ ] children
it was that guy no but no no this is the
dude this is my referral from goofy one
to goofy two
so and by the so chris is [ __ ] goofy
in a different way and like he's in a
good way [ __ ] like in a nice way yeah
being goofy's cool being uh yes exactly
different yes it's so subtle yeah so
chris graduated from college he's out
there working at interscope yeah you
know he's the interscope yes he doesn't
realize she's a hooker okay should you
pick up the second chris she's 19 20
years old we pick up her friend
the friend is a little bit older the
friend might be [ __ ] 40 for all i can
tell
okay
we get back they live in burbank in this
like i get there and i realize it's a
house but there's like eight people
living in this house and they're all 20
and they're all actors and they all pay
for a room
so they're from all over the world
yeah yeah yeah there's that
so i'm starting to piece all this
together i wasn't given the rundown on
the whole situation
yes
so you stand on the floor one of these
rooms whoa i know exactly where you
slept
i've been there
so
we sit down on the couch
and and her friend starts going
uh you know i'm i'm in like the
entertainment business like what are you
here for music i entertain dicks is what
she should have said so she goes
a couple times throughout the night she
had been like oh man maybe you should
give me some music for her like what
projects we're working on
all this [ __ ] now we're at the house
they're all doing bong rips and getting
comfortable and [ __ ] cool this [ __ ]
goes i produce veggie porn
she sticks vegetables horn that features
vegetables wait like vegetables banging
or she bangs herself with vegetables i
didn't ask you should have asked oh like
like you should have really asked like
yo are you trying to tell me that you
make vegetables have sex with each other
like breeding like like are you
cucumbers are you just slapping toys
together like kids or are you having sex
with you
chris's roommate goes do you know what
the [ __ ] he's here out you know what the
[ __ ] he's here for
this kid's got a record deal he's not
doing your porno [ __ ] are you [ __ ]
kidding yeah he's the 40 year old lady
yes you said that to her oh that's mean
oh that's but i was like in shock and
awe but in my mind i'm like fake buffalo
oh i do veggie porn marty just oh my
[ __ ] god take me back to the [ __ ]
buffalo
so far this holistic [ __ ] veggie porn
and a charger yep so i went to bed after
that so that was right after that
after that wait you're all in the same
room though
no it's a house
we were in the living room so i just
slept in the floor of one of the
bedrooms okay got you
so we so he scolded that woman
his christmas roommate did now they're
showing me commercials like they
literally showed me a nike commercial
they're all playing basketball and [ __ ]
but that's me that's me real quick like
flash across the street that's what this
house is yes
[Music]
i always found that kind of like sad
i always felt a little bad for those
because they really want it because the
one couple in there was like
screaming at each other the whole time
one of those
they're all scared of the landlord
they're all scared of the cops and the
weed they're acting like weed was
illegal
which was weird
but uh anyway so i wake up the next day
all right
we start driving through we start
driving to lax because he's got to take
his girl and drop her off she's going to
utas i remember she's going to utah so
he's taking her to lax but they're
fighting
the whole time the hooker yeah
yeah his girlfriend okay
so we're driving through hollywood and
we're with his this kid uh scott that is
chris's friend scott's
chill kind of hippie dude and we're just
driving through hollywood and they start
and then they get somebody from the ski
lodge calls me and goes he's about to
leave you're not even gonna get them
[ __ ] meet him he's about to fly out
he's going to toronto
so i was literally like let me out i
didn't even know where we were we were
in hollywood somewhere i hopped out and
said find me later
i remember i had the do you have a phone
oh yeah i had the iphone 4s okay i
remember because i was rapping about it
then the 4s yeah when i was 4s is right
when i started doing instagram mm-hmm me
too if you go i've had fans go back all
the way to the bottom of my timeline and
comment on the first post yeah and it's
funny it's from my four house
oh [ __ ] i love it like it's from this
time where it all started these pictures
i've talked about are the very first
pictures so uh okay so i hop out on foot
scott's had lived in hollywood he helps
me find the ski lodge we we're within
walking distance from where we hopped
out at
i get up i now what are the odds of that
very rare small odds it wasn't even off
hop out you just get there like a
[ __ ] sitcom it worked out to the
point that we walked up to the door but
now i had scott with me
which i wasn't inside thrilled about i
don't even know this dude i've been
going through so much [ __ ]
so
but it ended up working out good so like
we go in there i sit down i would have
been just sitting in there by myself in
the lobby but scott's with me so now i
kind of have somebody to talk to i'm not
just sitting there by myself i see ski
walk and this was huge at the time wiz
khalifa was just in there i heart
radio's in there nipsey hustler just
gotten signed to him recorded his album
in there all the big west coast acts
like ski was one of the biggest
legendary
west coast hip-hop djs period
so uh camera crews following him around
you know that was a shock though yeah
so then i just walk up to him he's like
what's up man what's up uh whatever
whatever kind of like
basically i mean bro i'm [ __ ] out
here over our deal it's public yeah
blaze tracks promoting this
um
but he just we slapped each other up and
he just [ __ ] left
so that's it no no i'm saying that's it
that's all you said that's all that was
it you we literally it was less than i
[ __ ] said to 50 cent oh
no
when you walked away were you did you
feel the heartbreak i didn't know i
wasn't going to talk to him again oh
[Laughter]
that wouldn't [ __ ]
so i just kind of sat back down because
i'm here to record i mean i'm out there
to record he just wanted to me before he
left type [ __ ] talk i didn't even
realize he was leaving i thought he's
gonna be there the whole [ __ ] time
i didn't know him leaving wasn't a part
of it
so
okay
so yeah he leaves now
i think i just leave maybe even come
back that night later okay no no this is
exactly what happened we okay so i
linked back up with chris he picked me
back up
uh they had given me a brand new beat
while i was there they're like this is
trap step we want to see if you can rap
because it was a licensing deal meaning
they placed songs that you make on video
games and when in tv shows and [ __ ] that
was the point of the record deals a
licensing deal so they gave me a brand
new beat i had all this music ready they
said here let's record this tomorrow
they gave me a brand new beat and it was
on some trap snap dubstep [ __ ]
okay
this is legendary in my world because i
took that beat back we made it back to
the house i took my little bit of weed
went back sat on the floor and just
zoned out
and i remember it was different than how
i wrote most songs because i just closed
my eyes and i wrote on a blank page
all the most random words that could
come to mind from just this crazy little
chapter i was in
and then i just kind of looked at it and
i just picked out random words i ended
up picking out kiwi nights purple days
wait stop is this how you made songs
that's how i made this song you just
wrote down words
just in this case this isn't how i
usually did it okay okay but i usually
don't write and record the next day i
usually have the song memorized before i
even go in i've worked it out i've
recorded a rough copy got you they're
putting me on the spot
i have [ __ ] prepared so i mean i go in
there i blank it out i blank out i have
the song memorized by the time i'm done
writing it
which is
different by the time i wake up that
morning i'm ready to go now
another funny layer of the story
his girl's gone so it's me and chris now
which is what i wanted because chris is
cool and he's an engineer and [ __ ] like
we're about to execute
uh but
chris's girl has a kid and this is her
car
the challenger they have is hers and her
baby daddies
okay and they have a kid together
now her baby daddy is
debo for all intents and purposes this
fool's fresh out of prison he looks like
debo he acts like debo
he's the real life [ __ ] debo out of
south central
all right
oh no
so now oh
no
[Laughter]
go
so now uh chris is like
uh bro do you think we could use the car
to like drop my boy off at the studio
her [ __ ]
new boyfriend yes goofy ass okay chris
is probably 19.
he's calling her baby daddy this fool's
probably 33. that's so [ __ ] pathetic
it's like uh it's like a reality show
okay on the bus
he had the car
he had the their car okay the dad the
baby chris chris had we had the car oh
so but it was like the dad needed it to
drive the kid back and forth to school
and [ __ ] also oh so he's calm like yo
i'm gonna take the car we're trying to
work it out the dude ended up being cool
as [ __ ] okay debo all right but it was
funny as [ __ ] because the dynamic
between him and chris father is yes
it was [ __ ] hilarious with the you
know your baby's mom but
well i'm her driver and you come to find
out well we've never kissed i mean she's
i want to go out with her
that's what i think happened and she was
just her driver some [ __ ] like that i
mean it might have been i don't know i
only witnessed those few hours with them
maybe he thought it was his girlfriend
and she was like this is just
me around might have very well done that
because it doesn't sound that's a weird
but i think she kind of i think she
lived in that house too it's a weird
dynamic that's super weird because now
the whole time i'm there
this dude eddie's driving me around but
that first time was surreal eddie
eddie's the uh he's the baby daddy deebo
deebo
yeah i didn't say his name but no reason
what the [ __ ] this dude is and he didn't
do anything wrong he's awesome yeah he's
cool i'm just saying like
dude
don't worry i'll drive you around yeah
get your
record deal exactly
so now
we're going down to south central this
dude's got hey you are so dedicated yeah
yeah you're so [ __ ] dedicated to be
going no i'll get in the car with this
guy oh he's banging your baby's mom
you just got a prison
[Laughter]
it was like
it was so sick though he put my music on
he got weed out of the trunk we're
rolling around south south pumping my
[ __ ] yeah he was cool once he realized
he liked me that's cool never mind this
turned into a cool day then it was cool
i've never been in south central before
i'm seeing all the streets from boys in
the hood and south central and [ __ ]
like i'm doing it but yeah we're
thumping my music and [ __ ] you know it
was cool so then he takes me up to the
studio
i get to the studio who's the engineer i
don't know if i ever told you this
[ __ ] nick hogan
why
because he's an engineer
the hulk hogan's son yes
what the [ __ ]
i had no idea it was going to be him she
woke up what's up hulk hogan's son and
it was only us we had the whole ski
lodge to ourself because he was out of
town yes
so for like extended so i went in we did
this for like six seven days straight
you just went to the studio recorded and
recorded recorded music yes the music
you had you already had or the reasons
they wanted you to make both
that first day i went in there and
smashed that [ __ ] they had given me the
night before with a [ __ ] passion no
paper
we went in there i gave nick hogan the
beat he was like oh [ __ ] because he's on
that like club dj [ __ ]
and then he loved it we vibed out we
were good friends he was cool as [ __ ]
that whole time we were on skis balcony
[ __ ] blowing down dutch or
jays and [ __ ]
in front of the ski lodge we had the
place to ourselves we were [ __ ]
chilling yo you have the best experience
and you can not go back to buffalo at
that point
i did you know i'm saying you can't i
know mentally you can't
that's the next part of the story yeah
but uh yeah it was [ __ ] amazing
because i mean it was like you couldn't
ask for a better experience oh yeah you
you can't debo just decide to go damn
your music's tight get that weed out of
the trunk
oh [ __ ] yeah like that's great i'll have
protection this guy's gonna beat people
up they're trying to beat me up uh-huh
we can go to gang lane let's go
yo it was kind of like that that's
exactly what happened yeah you had a
hall hood pass
it was like don't worry man bump it
uh-huh yo that's a great ex that's a
great experience i was so sick and you
know like i
i think i even had to borrow some money
like spending money to be out here like
i was just and and mind you i'm just out
here by myself too i don't have my kid
out of my daughter i'm completely
focused on music for people creatives
like that any time where you like travel
somewhere for the purpose of creating
and you're locked out and you don't have
any other responsibilities that's like a
special moment
especially in music it's more 100 it's
most and most most people are doing
things that cause you to create yeah
like if there's a block on your head
when you're doing [ __ ] in your normal
life when you get out of your normal
routine it's like that's why i really
[ __ ] with the rick rubin the way he does
a lot of stuff everyone's just isolated
yeah like no no you're an artist
put your phone down yeah yeah yeah
exactly like shut the [ __ ] up and work i
love it dude it's just
it's like a think tank
but yeah yourself yeah but it was all
for something because prior to that i've
been a studio rap my whole life i've
lived in the studio for years prior to
that even as a little kid i grew up in
the studio yeah cause you did yeah
but now it was four something and it was
in cali and it wasn't us in a closet on
the [ __ ] [ __ ] sun just nick
hogan's words all right yeah so and
everybody's got weed everybody's got
weed in their little jars and [ __ ] i had
never seen weed in prescription bottles
i would say prescription yeah yeah
that's what everyone had there and when
the first weed we got that first night i
got here his girl ran in got the weed
came out she's like it's dr dre og i was
like oh [ __ ] because i was on a mission
to meet i was on a mission to get a dr
dre record deal yeah uh so we were
talking about that but anyway yeah i did
10 days and then i went the [ __ ] back to
buffalo so when you went back to buffalo
getting on that plane until you landed
you still had that motivation when you
land you go oh yeah i gotta get out of
here well it would have been real bad
because i went back so now i go back
it's late september it's already getting
cold oh this is a movie in my head i
know because you know what's crazy is
i'm not looking at you over here yeah
it's we're talking it's like we're on
facetime yeah because sometimes for
people that don't know sometimes we'll
be setting up and we're three hours
later we're starting to film because
we just talk for three hours about crazy
random story like wait what happened so
that's why i know a lot of your stories
but have we talked about them while
filming no i don't really ever i don't
know i have the luxury of popping in and
out
finding one liner
and then i leave now it's like no no
hear the story so so far this is like a
[ __ ] this is like
i could see this being a movie i love it
yeah so now you're going back after the
sick ass 10-day stay
in bob california and i had just had all
these epic falling outs with all my
friends so it was a big like [ __ ]
told you i was going to do this [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah
oh
that's sad too yeah
you know i'm not going to come out here
and stand on hollywood boulevard with my
[ __ ] mixtapes nah [ __ ] i did it the
right way too yeah oh two months [ __ ]
longer
yeah two months longer for real
so you get back and now you're like what
april we're gonna move yes well
she came and visited her friend in dana
point and after it which is like guys if
you've ever visited socal everybody
where's dana point
it's southern orange county it's like
beautiful towards you yes
where are you i live yeah wherever you
live that visits l.a needs to visit
south orange county because go past
orange county if you come to la la's
great there's shops and you know dirty
ass streets it's dope i love it out here
it's the city where you're at yeah is
when they show pictures of california
beaches and families and trees that's
where he lives
and that's where april came
on the beach oh she [ __ ] can't go
back so she's like yeah we'll do it for
sure and that was just a few months
after because mind you now i came back
and i'm gearing up to release california
campaign the cd those songs are on
california campaign produced by nick
hogan
engineered by nick hogan
i mean there was a track on there that
was produced by uh nipsey's producer
because he's in-house at ski music and
all my producers i have a whole [ __ ]
team of producers at that point
um
so we premiered it on games website rap
the rapper the game yeah i was in with
them and we dropped it on his website so
i had that that i was working towards
but when i got back they started acting
funny at the ski lodge too
like as all music related things do
really in the sense that
he became a tv host
like him and mark cuban started a tv
network he they like
shortly after i left they took the
recording studios out of the ski lodge
oh so they were like oh we're kind of
done with music because they had a
licensing division of the ski lodge it
was called build destroyed music that
was the whole thing that was the whole
it was this whole thing when you got
back it's like well we don't exist
they're kind of like yeah we're kind of
doing tv with mark cuban now so we're
not really like paying attention to this
anymore yeah it was that but that was
slow because it was i mean
it was a couple months before we still
moved we ended up moving out in like
july so how much longer after you came
to california and visited and went back
how much longer after you i came back in
september we moved in like july
oh nice yeah stayed up and then took off
so yeah i was working a collections job
which [ __ ] killed my soul like i was
telling you but i was making connections
through it like looking at people's
numbers and [ __ ] that's how we met
[ __ ] brian counts
stop
yo if you're dedicated and you really
want something to work you will be marty
yeah marty don't skip over the [ __ ] like
hey you know there's just like a little
part i know brian knows it i didn't want
to like next time he comes we'll talk
about it last episode you had a story
ready for brian and when we left i went
did you even tell your story last week's
episode i i didn't even really like my
joint
i don't know why i was just lost in the
conversation yeah
don't skip over that [ __ ]
martin used to work in the collections
i'm saying you used to work in
collections
and you were doing what watching joe
rogan's podcast watching the fighter and
the kid was like no fighter in the kid
didn't exist yet okay tell this story
what happened why did you call brian
count what's the point well my method
with music and this is all alleged and
beyond seven years ago
this is all a hypothetical scenario but
i would i'd [ __ ] look up i had a
rolodex of the whole music industries
and like phone numbers and [ __ ] i'd call
i'd call you to death i'd call your
grandmother to get you on the phone i've
talked to
a lot of famous people's family trying
to get them on the phone to pitch them
my [ __ ] no
no you're taking them from the collect
from the collections and rolodex yeah
because like we're talking about like
skip tracing like oh [ __ ] could you find
out somebody's address like it's a
no-brainer you could you find out
everybody's
phone numbers and the people they live
with phone numbers went like when you're
trying to find somebody to pay a bill
yeah you know so like a good for
instance when i did that whole make your
own luck campaign with rob dierdak i got
his [ __ ] aunt on the phone
and then i got big cat on the phone his
cousin that did fantasy factory i'm like
bro i just give him the rundown
how did you get my number i'll say the
first thing how'd you get my [ __ ]
number don't worry about this thing i
got yeah don't worry about it he needs
that listen he favored it on twitter i
needed it like it was like that
you're that guy i was at that time
that's dedication and if you don't come
off like a weird i might go
okay yeah i never came off like a weirdo
yeah i just if you did come off like a
weird like yo it don't very [ __ ] call
me
yeah be very easy for following me but i
made real connections you really tried
like this guy went out of his way to
[ __ ] find us yeah
i'm not doing psycho [ __ ] for the sake
of doing psycho [ __ ] but i'm trying to
get you on the phone
[Laughter]
no it's just aggressive
that's just what everybody else no i
just agree
as he admits it's psycho [ __ ] what are
they going to do
not sign me to their record deal i'm
already there yeah i get you but that's
how i got in touch with kayla why did
you want to get in touch with him
because he was blowing rogan's podcast
was early on he was one of the first one
of rogan's friends that got blown up by
the podcast he started his own podcast
at bryant country which i was listening
to in this timeframe and he had a
[ __ ] t-shirt contest going and you're
already doing graphics yes i was
hustling graphics the whole time
from
the very start of me doing music you
just
randomly knew how to do just started my
cousin gave me a computer on my 19th
birthday it had photoshop and i learned
it really yeah so that he left that out
i didn't know that yeah i didn't know
how you started learning graphics yeah
he gave that completely changed my life
he gave me a computer on my 19th
birthday my cousin from detroit i was
telling you about yeah he drove in he
gave it to me me and jamal were there he
brought a [ __ ] rental jaguar he had
he led us driving around the
neighborhood and [ __ ] he was one of the
best days of my life he gave me the
computer had photoshop and adobe
audition
that
was like a defining moment in my life
because i started recording myself in
the basement on adobe audition and
started doing photo graphics for myself
as a rapper but then i started doing it
for all my boys everything yeah we're
recording in the basement i was doing
all our graphics i was doing our music
videos like i had a whole label a little
yeah and you're [ __ ] filming and
you're taking pictures and you're doing
all that [ __ ] yeah yeah so that's how i
mean that's how really that all kind of
like
so you had a t-shirt contest and you and
so he had a t-shirt contest and i called
him
and he got his number it was him on his
voicemail and you called him and just
said hey like i just you know i got some
teacher designs for you i just if i can
send them to you let me know and then he
texted me back and i sent him the
designs and then we went back and forth
but nothing really ever happened
he never used them did you win he never
paid me for anything i don't [ __ ]
know no i don't think so
i don't know it wasn't even that big of
a deal we just kind of made a quick
brief connection and i said i'm going to
move to california
and then when i moved to california i
was telling you today we went and we
were looking at cell phone printers
when i first moved here i couldn't get a
[ __ ] job in buffalo okay i had all
these had skills i was super hard worker
i literally couldn't hold a job outside
of collections which i hated with a
extreme passion within four days of
being here i got a job doing graphics
and printing
you know what city it was right by where
i live oh okay you know printing the
cell phone case yeah
so uh
um where where was i going
you moved to your four days and you were
like brian cal and you made it oh yeah
yeah so i was i was running the printers
one day and i was listening to him on
rogan to talk about that they were going
to start the fighter in the kid and i
just had this like real-to-snick moment
of like inspiration like hit that
[ __ ] up
so i right i was running the printers i
remember i just put the [ __ ] down
started printing and i went into my
email hey bry i made it out to
california i heard you're starting a new
podcast let me know if you guys can use
any help
and then literally within a half hour
later i got an email from brendan
like you know
what are you talking about so then they
just hired me to do some t-shirt designs
so i did a couple t-shirt designs for
him
and that's right but it was before
episode one
so then on episo episode one rolls
around like the night before and he goes
hey we need a graphic art for today's
episode it needs to be about the episode
it's going to go up first thing in the
morning and we need it to be a cartoon
so
now i have to listen to the episode come
up with a creative concept about the
episode that makes sense into a graphic
and make it into a cartoon which i had
never done before and it's gonna go out
in front of all these raging fans first
thing in the morning and it's your first
project and tomorrow and it's tomorrow
yeah
so that's how you started
yeah so then
i really cut my teeth with fighter and
the kid
and it was very similar to this in the
sense like what the [ __ ] does that mean
cut my teeth like uh i've never heard
that expression my entire life it's like
being a newbie at something like getting
really cut my teeth
fans out there i think people know that
one
i hope they do this pulls out you're
making [ __ ] no that's something i didn't
make that i really buttered my dick with
that one yeah
is that what you just said i was making
[ __ ] up party actually what i did is i
saw that banana thing it looked like a
stick of butter went buttered on my dick
i'm just trying to think of a word um
sorry you started the graphics got the
graphics they said good job you're hired
yeah and then
i wasn't even getting paid for that at
that point i had to kind of earn that
but the show started to blow up and we
started to perform live and that started
i mean it was [ __ ] amazing those
first two years was amazing the fans
when did the show start 2014. oh it's
relatively new
not really it's under 10 years yeah yeah
but they're an episode like [ __ ] 700
or whatever
but
yeah i mean i was there for the first
live performance but
i wasn't i was only dealing with the
podcast but then my business grew when
brennan became a a live stand-up act
because as business you mean yourself
trash is great doing this yourself
though yes so you're like this is my i
do that i do that too i do that and you
just wouldn't learn it getting my degree
paying
through four times when you're schooled
right yes
working a full-time job cam was a
newborn two babies now
iran's five we are living in irvine it's
expensive as [ __ ] i'm working a
full-time job i've got a family and
april's a realtor still
yeah she had a job at the time she was
doing real estate but i'm working 24
hours a day now because
once to build that show up i was a huge
part of of i was the tip of the spear of
our whole social media i did every
graphic we ever made all our t-shirt
everything so all the fire in the kids
[ __ ] not to mention i had to do an
episode graphic every monday
about the episode
the same night turnaround
you gotta listen to the episode come up
with a creative concept if it's gonna be
a parody or
whatever
there's no room for revisions
sometimes i would have to sit there and
listen to the episode three four five
times pick something out that made sense
it's a lot of work dude so much it's a
lot of work that's why it's high
pressure yes say there's so much
pressure on you especially going nah
don't fire me
don't fire me
fans don't roast this [ __ ] when we post
it
cause that's the other thing were you
running their social media at the time
no oh so you couldn't be like hey i'm a
racist no but the fans did nothing but
ever show love though at that point so
but then as things grew
i circled once i really started to kind
of help brendan blow up in his stand-up
career in terms of booking right yeah in
terms of like all the live promotional
graphics the targeted ad campaigns in
each city the website the email blast
the merch all that type of [ __ ] that
goes into touring
fool did a world tour in the first year
doing comedy off of live live podcasting
like i'm talking about us doing yeah
like brian was talking about he did five
minutes to open the show five minutes to
open the show next thing you know the
fool's doing the [ __ ] face
yeah yeah
you know but then
brian became like a client of mine as
brian kalin
and then you know now i'm managing all
his live shows and his whole brand but
with brian i was probably the most
hands-on of all my clients like i
[ __ ] do i handled everything for him
uh but then like same thing for theo and
then rogan so you know and then like
josh and sickler so so you're literally
just picking up all these mainstream
uh comedians
social lives
um um
every social media thing yeah their
promotion for their everything you do
their live performances yeah and each
one of those things four or five hours
you're working 20 seconds well they're
constantly throwing [ __ ] at me so you're
working non-stop no it's not because in
their mind like yeah marty can get it
done but yeah
you rogan and theo just did the same
thing at the same time
but you all wanted the jack this hour
oh that's how it went for like five
years
and school and all this and i was
working a job and all this [ __ ] so like
yeah when did you how long into the
drastic graphics did you were able to
quit your day job 2017. how long did you
start drastic graphics 14 17. now when
did you start i mean when did you start
doing that the first time i mean i like
i said right when i started paying you
what year was that was like 2015 2016
for two years you were [ __ ] working a
regular job
i was doing that [ __ ] for free but for
the whole time before that though i was
doing it through brendan like yo brian
needs a graphic for this brian is the
graphic for that brown needs a graphic
and then i had to take control of the
situation and be like we gotta make
sense of this because it's too [ __ ]
much yeah your brain you can't anytime
yeah like i posted today on twitter so
there it is you put in two [ __ ]
full years of free work day in day out
to get where you needed to be in a
position see that it's not [ __ ]
overnight you're not gonna gain a
million followers in a month
you're not going to get paid what you
want today
[ __ ] work it worked for seven years
for free but i was also having a hell of
fun yeah you are just grinding away it
was fun to me i love being in a great
just saying like three hours
i don't have the pressure because
there's no glory in that being that far
behind the scenes i might as well about
a million miles away like i was
completely remote and removed from the
situation yeah but i didn't give a [ __ ]
like all i wanted was to do is build my
reputation which i did that's what you
were doing when i started like naming
off all those names it wasn't cause like
oh they're just giving them to me like i
made my connection with theo became my
client before he even started before he
ever even went on fighter in the kid
oh really but then theo really blew up
threw fighter in the kid and rogan
so what were you doing for theo just the
graphics and everything's too it started
with t-shirt designs and then it rolled
into episode graphics and then it rolled
into the live tour management promotions
just like
this just such a trip though that you're
you're running and this is just a few
years after moving here mm-hmm
yeah yeah you needed a move man i was
doing this while i was in school
[ __ ] for graphics yeah
bro you didn't even have time to sleep
at that point yeah it was a lot i mean
it took a lot it was a lot it was a real
lot because i mean i wasn't making a lot
of money we were still like not having
barely any money because our cost of
living was super high now
so yeah that like i i always remember
the really really huge chasm
the really huge big milestone after
moving here was being able to quit the
day job and focus on drastic full time
but even then i was still working 24
hours a day you have to be you're not an
employee until this year yeah
yeah that helped out a lot oh my god
then the interesting thing is like we
grew it to the point so much
while i did have an employee that like
i was able to scale back clients which
was the ultimate goal and right now you
literally
shaved off ninety percent of your
clients yeah
just because we need so much time
because i can now and uh yeah because
this is my primary focus that from day
one that was the plan that was the goal
like i hope to god i can do that because
i couldn't have sustained the way i was
going just with my family brain would
have broke yeah it wasn't fun it was no
there's no yeah cool you work with all
these cool people but
the [ __ ] doesn't mean you don't do
anything you don't get health insurance
you don't get
weekends you don't get a time like
eventually that [ __ ] runs thin so i just
always i've always known there's been
levels
and you can still do graphics and [ __ ]
when you hire a team like exactly i'm
not doing anymore yeah i'm hiring a team
of me's yeah i could totally do that
yeah that's just not my focus maybe in
this right now no no not right now yeah
right now we're in the start-up this is
exactly this is episode 31. yeah exactly
this is not i'm not i'm not
uh i'm not greedy enough to think or
maybe greedy's not the right word but i
know when something's special when it
needs your attention give it to it
because special things only come around
once in a great while like and if you're
lucky enough to be a part of it once
i'm i have the experience of being a
part of something special like that
but i was just like a support player so
i know how it can go what can happen
what to do how like
what can go wrong you've seen this whole
entire podcast thing already yeah
like
you know and if you if you really look
at everybody that's done podcasting it's
so new that particular scenario is super
unique nobody's done it like that
nobody's come out of the gate
so you're talking about firing the kid
yeah yeah in terms of just
the live shows and just that first two
years
because it was when rogan was really
making the transition from just being
like a hit big podcast like the biggest
show in the world yeah they you know and
the ufc too like conor mcgregor even
mcgregor was one of our first guests
you know like when we were on fox sports
oh no [ __ ] yeah so you know
but uh yeah so but i don't work with
them anymore and i don't work with you
know
a lot a lot of people really so this is
his focus
yeah
because i can i remember saying times
like
marty if we don't get the dopaziola
video channel dopa's yolo channel video
done don't trip let's just do it
tomorrow because i know you got nine
other fools going hey marty can you get
this done but that's the other thing
dope is yola is also my other main like
dope once we started working together
and it was like really allowed me to
realize like
i'm really not a graphic designer either
i'm really like i really like video more
graphic design kind of supports the
video they're just fun and you were my
first client where it was predominantly
videos yeah but then we were able to
circle it back and have it be like full
brand management basically with like
when we really put together the thought
for dopaziola.com and how we needed it
to function
and
get set up it took a year then you know
how long it took to build that [ __ ]
site it took a long time um but i mean
[ __ ] now we're like we're set up the
right way and we're up and running we
have options we can do these
pay-per-view events we're talking about
we can
so
what marty's talking about is before
we'll we'll get right back on topic
sorry before we get off topic marty and
i are thinking about doing a
pay-per-view
like
five bucks watch this video
i know it's like wait so you're charging
for content it's more like this
what if we do it on our website because
youtube we can't say everything we want
to say we can't show everything we want
to show have you ever seen a pound of
weed on the table during a podcast
no because youtube's going to get pissed
but if we do our own pay-per-view i can
have 150 pounds on the stable and just
swim yeah things like that but we're not
talking about that we're talking about
i don't want to give it all away but
what if we'd like a three-on-three
tournament like all right all the guests
come back we're gonna all because it'd
be kind of funny to see that all right
cool and then it's just it it depends on
what we want but either way we can be
uncensored
and we're thinking okay so we charge
people five bucks they can come watch
the video
it's a good trade it's good
i love it i like that because it's in
line with like um we were saying the
comedians selling their stand-up
specials off their own website for five
bucks for you know an hour but what if
it was our and and what if we get to do
a podcast in a giant grow room yeah sure
do the show for months so today we're in
600 pounds we do the three-on-three
tournament and then we like watch and
react to it from the grow room [ __ ] like
that two days later everybody's still
sore ah we're just watching and laughing
[ __ ] that video well just trimming up
weed so what do you do so i you know i'm
from [ __ ] buffalo man
i don't know what i don't we don't know
yet we're just thinking of that idea so
drop a comment if you like that idea if
you like that concept let us know we're
just we're brainstorming out here okay
we want to put out more podcast branded
stuff that's not necessarily the podcast
yes just
different stuff maybe a different
segment yeah
get creative with it as things continue
to grow because it's hard for me and my
brain because it's like all right the
adventures of yolo channel family
friendly so much dope is your channel
say whatever the [ __ ] you want podcast
say whatever you want but hold back a
little bit because we are also on
youtube yes
and it's like okay so where's the
uncensored all of it mixed
okay what do i do
how do i word this what do i do to make
it different because i'm the same person
how do you make the same person do four
different
styles of things it's hard yeah for sure
it's hard and in my head i'm like so
what am i gonna do
well i just won't cuss that sucks
changing myself like creating out of the
wrong space when you're doing that yeah
i feel like i'm not trying to be myself
but it's like no i am that's why it
always comes back to the same thing and
i always start why [ __ ] because that's
just who i am i'm not going to be able
to change it but we're thinking about
that like how could be uncensored
because i'm pretty uncensored i know we
really when i watch the podcast back
though it's like i mean
it's pretty clean
yeah we don't go crazy we don't go crazy
especially with the clips and the titles
and the thumbnails like we really
g-rated as much yes
like we talk about some [ __ ] on here
but
i would like to say different things
sometimes and i go
no youtube might just go hey unplug that
channel yeah it's so we don't want him
to say that again channel's so valuable
to us now oh we'll just play it nice
[ __ ] and when we start doing
live shows get ready exactly i'm gonna
throw dildos at the [ __ ] audience or
i don't know just some ridiculous
quick idea i have ready
you heard it here first
you ever seen a rocker rocky horror
picture show
uh tim curry you know who tim curry is
motion it's not rocky horror picture
show the rocky horror picture show
okay that's what it's called science
motion theater oh that's that's
something different okay all right rocky
horror picture show is you know tim
curry his
yeah or no tim curry from the guy that
played it yeah
he plays uh transvestites what they
called it sweet transvestite was like i
don't know where his name was
anyway it's like a
very sexual weird it was a it's a good
movie but it's a musical
and my mom
shout out to my mom she told me when she
was younger
during the show at the theater they
would have people go like say you go to
amc and rock your picture it's 1970
something 1980 right
they go hey reach under your sheet under
your seat at this time and on the screen
will be like beep beep beep
and the people that work at the theater
act as characters and they run through
the theater during certain parts of the
show so in the movie when he pulls up a
newspaper you pull up a newspaper and
everyone pulls it out the same time and
it's like the move so it's like you're
oh what the [ __ ] and like okay so pull
this out at the same time when you do
it's like you should be smelling this
smell like
whoa because on the screen like say the
guy's peeling the orange and then you
smell the whole theater just orange mist
and like
it's kind of like
what was it what would you say like an
embarrassing immerse thank you immersive
it's
[ __ ] cool so i was thinking
what if we one of these episodes at the
end go hey so next week guys do us a
favor if you can have like some duct
tape
this a pair of scissors an apple
this and that
just wait and during the episode
while we're say i plan the stories i'm
gonna talk about and say i'm like i was
running and i
fell through this and it smelled like
this like what if i can plan the stories
i'm gonna talk about
and then pick a thing in between or
story from yours like next week you're
gonna need these six items and we put it
up on the screen as i'm saying goodbye
and then the next time we do it we
during our video edit we just put up
grab your apple in five four three and
then just
as everybody's eating
so i was walking right and i was eating
this apple pie and i was doing some [ __ ]
i don't know i was trying to think of
like how do i make the audience feel
even more into the show because i know
the fourth shot when we were with eric
con goblin me it felt like you guys were
at the end of the table oh yeah that's
how i felt when i was watching it too
so what if we can be like that's funny
all right what's up guys grab your ready
go so i was running through this orchard
i don't know i'm just trying to think of
things that would involve a smell or a
thing or a feeling or a look
just a thought i like that my mom
explained that symbiosis with the fans
yeah i don't know my mom told me wait
what so like they had a newspaper and
she's like yeah and then the guy dressed
up like him would run right down the
aisle and just scare the [ __ ] out of
people
sounds
odd yeah for sure but cool they do that
at disneyland well they're like see yeah
the mist with the uh the shrek thing
where they spray the smells yeah that's
what i'm trying to say yeah yeah yeah
yeah
exactly but for podcasts and you got to
do it yourself yeah except for like the
episodes you're talking about your mom
all right i'll punch yourself in the
face yeah so right right now what you're
going to want to do is you should you
stab you stab right by your kidneys and
then you slap yourself be real scared
start sweating
be mad and scared be mad scared and
sweat and start to sweat hold your
breath until you start sweating
yo
no we're not gonna do that but a bag of
stuff or hey next week you're gonna need
these items
if you want
i don't know
sounds kind of awesome
leave a comment do you like that idea
too so three on three or pay-per-view
tournament rocky horror picture show
style um
episode
it could be fun oh yeah maybe for
halloween uh-huh
yeah we got halloween just dressed up as
something like all right so you're gonna
need this candy this candy and then next
weekend this this this this and this
bro that's not a bad idea i'm worth all
that time i like it
see these are our face time
conversations we were in a whole movie
of your life and then went hey you're
nobody's checker
right
so now
boom it's 2017 you're starting to get
paid you're picking up now you're joe
rogan's guy your theo vaughn
uh brian
sickler josh wolfe all these people
you're doing it for years you're just
managing all their social media managing
all their stuff ticket sales concerts
this
you're funky it's not like you did it
because they're they're hilarious it
doesn't work without them yeah but i'm
saying like for all the stuff that
people don't want to do you're the guy
knocking all of it out
and and selling out the arenas like
target marketing target marketing [ __ ]
yeah every single day they go to
there's a whole ad campaign associated
and that's the [ __ ] behind the scenes
that you never think and i'm dealing
with live nation and with wme and caa
and all their agents and
all the the venues you act as a manager
i play a lot of that managerial role for
a lot of them i have in the past big
time wow yeah
that's awesome it gave me a lot of
really good experience yeah for sure to
do it for us yeah i used to do i mean we
see this [ __ ] in action all the [ __ ]
time
guys i got to be honest with me and
marty started we're like yo if we could
just do this a month we'll be happy all
right well we just do and now it's like
it's working
cool yeah holy [ __ ] actual business now
it's crazy
it's fun to be like oh we got paid to
come in today
we were just hoping before we were just
hoping not only did it have to work it
had to work fast and it did and it did
and it did so thank you guys so much i
promise you'll never see a scandal
you'll never see us doing some dumb [ __ ]
we'll never do some wild things
i promise we're never gonna
marty o'neill beat the [ __ ] out of april
like you're not gonna find that all
right
you won't do nothing as long as your
minds are peasy
she just smacked you in the arm right
now why you guys watch this
while you're watching this back she's
slapping you in the arm and i feel like
you should record her right when she's
popping up
just to get that inception thing going
on
wear the shirt yeah yeah um
i'm [ __ ] high
so
now we're catching up
to your demo music you're doing all of
this
podcasting behind the scenes of so
people that like podcast and watch that
you were there for all of that [ __ ] yep
and i started like being involved with
like when rogan released his last
netflix basketball
cool
you know i started getting involved with
like netflix i started doing the cover
art for the specials the trailers for
the specials being involved with the
production companies of the specials you
know just kind of like kind of moving up
levels and levels you know within that
and then i put out the book full-time
podcast for me and my boy nick who's
theo's producer we put out full-time
podcaster nick is uh super cool yeah
next cool um nick just link possibly
linked us with adam corolla to get him
to come on the show yesterday
because nick used to work for house
right yeah that's what that's how i've
that's how i work i ended up working for
adam corolla
through dick through nick yeah
um so then we yeah we put out the book
and the book was a big thing because
it's like
you know you get really horrible margins
where can everybody find that
uh audible amazon apple it's called
full-time podcaster
um if you go to fulltimepodcaster.com
with hyphens in between the words that
you know that's the craziest thing
not ready full time podcast is your
full-time job
now it is
so is graphics
[Music]
so is editing all of our other videos
it's two different businesses i know
you're a full-time podcaster in this 12
hours
area
in this 12-hour area we're editing all
these crazy videos doing crazy [ __ ] so
it's not like
we're trying to do all this stuff while
having four lives on top of it and
remember you have three kids and you're
married you can't just be like oh yeah
by the way they're growing up all
[ __ ] guys over there no [ __ ] that
every time i [ __ ] call you
someone's hanging off your body and then
choking you and [ __ ] yeah so it's like
a lot of the podcasting people like yeah
you guys are crushing you guys are doing
like i can't wait until we can [ __ ]
focus on this
yeah be a full-time podcaster and it can
do it well it will event eventually sure
we just spread ourselves we're doing it
organically and we're taking the stairs
yeah we're doing the long route we could
have and not dissing anyone at all i'm
just saying like he's got their own we
already started on the [ __ ] long
route so we're not going to go switch up
now
yeah you work just as long as i do
except you get up early and sleep at
night and i'd stay up all night and get
up at 11. yeah
different shows it's just different
shifts it truly is what time you're
asleep oh yeah i went to bed five hours
ago four hours ago i [ __ ]
i hate it i hate it so much
um
but
but yeah so i put out the book and i
didn't make any money off the book but
it really made a big statement and i
knew that was going to happen it just
stamped me and nick at the top of this
industry
in terms of the behind the scenes people
because when you put out something
educational on a subject you become an
authority in that subject people okay
respect your knowledge you're not doing
this oh i'm not gonna tell you exactly
[ __ ] like that man i can't
stand people like oh you're doing great
oh you're doing really good
that is big and probably the artistic
style community i mean i was talking
about the other day
it's big everywhere yeah yeah yeah yeah
dicks
but yeah no i'm not like that at all
because i mean [ __ ] i know i can do
better word about that nobody's gonna
take my job at this point i'm not
worried about that
so i would rather just kind of claim
myself at the top of this industry a la
the hip-hop industry in the 90s and like
we always talk about the record execs
and the [ __ ] that ran that
just you know i know i know that me and
nick are that to podcasting so that's
why you guys run you guys make things
function i'm not saying nobody else can
i'm just saying you guys are the ones
been doing it with these successful
shows and have the track record record
to show because podcasting is new
it's truly it's newer than the [ __ ]
internet yeah the internet's like 30
years old yeah podcast is like what 15
yeah
for i mean for real for real
yeah
corolla's really the first one
yeah you're set you were telling me that
rola rogan that whole cloth but mark
maron in them but
we put that out and then i
right before that i could tell
even though i had gotten to the point
where i had stacked up all these clients
and i was working a lot but i was also
like able to not have to work a
full-time job anymore
i could tell it still wasn't going to be
enough
and i really started looking up to peter
mckinnon from youtube we always talk
about we always references and i really
really
always looked up to the photographer
there was just something about the
photographer
he could show up and be there on site he
showed he has a special he has a tool it
was like my dad with a guitar he could
show up and play his guitar [ __ ]
anywhere in the world he doesn't even
think about it he just does it and i
knew that the next step i had to take
was to learn the camera
i knew how to edit
i had no idea how the camera worked
whatsoever
zero percent what year is this
uh
since then 2015 19 17 18 i think oh okay
we met in january 2020. yeah that's when
we met we barely we barely met yeah it
feels like it's been like 10 years yeah
yeah it really does so we're talking
like probably
2018 2019 and i just completely
dedicated myself to studying
videography and photography
see that's what happens when you're like
no i have to take i have to be really
good at it you do what you did
you know you did like no i'm gonna take
the time and i'm gonna study it for a
year but then the thing beyond that is
that you have to invest a bunch of money
into it yeah that's one of the things
that you don't have
so i got a credit card and spent ten
thousand on it my first goal your stuff
without testing or using any equipment
ever just based off my research my
psychotic research yeah you do a lot of
that
so
and luckily i made good choices i'm
really happy with the choices i made in
terms of what i bought in my first
purchase
and now we're getting close
after i get into this goddamn house for
a while and settle down we're talking
about like and making that second round
of investments into new camera equipment
because the stuff i got is good but
it could there's a whole another level
above it yeah but that's uh i want to
make a video about that because that's a
problem every photographer and
videographer that's new faces there's
all this information out there there's
so many different pieces of equipment
they're all so expensive what am i
actually going to need yeah because
unless you know somebody you can't go
test this [ __ ] out and canon versus soji
versus nikon versus go rent all that
[ __ ] too if you wanted to if you want to
test it out most people don't do that
they're just [ __ ] most people aren't
in l.a where there's 30 places to rent
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying we're
lucky we always think like well you
don't have something like you're an la
[ __ ] so it's the mecca of stuff
i got my [ __ ] my first gig ever was theo
vaughn live at the world turn dry run
for filmmakers yes bts
oh [ __ ]
my first photo shoot ever was theo
vaughn ratchet when he won the uh title
of guess this year on fighter and kid
yeah
so my first i was literally been there
every step of the way day in day out
every episode every graphic every post
everything i have every episode in
chronological order in their file
every file i have every file ever still
organized for every live show every
apparel drop every promo drop every
i have everything i've ever done
completely organized wow yeah i know
that's cool though but being able to go
back like well that was my first got
here yeah
in this chapter and then now we're on a
new developed into my own style you know
we did a lot of parody stuff parody [ __ ]
is not easy to do it's super [ __ ]
hard really yeah because you're so
limited in what you can do if i'm
parodying a movie poster i gotta find
the person that i'm putting on the
poster like in the exact same position
as the person exactly the lighting and
the positioning and what makes sense and
and okay there's text and there's logos
on this goddamn poster i gotta remove
them so i can put my own text and logos
on it each one takes like an hour oh god
i mean depending
can take all [ __ ] night i've pulled
so many all-nighters doing this [ __ ]
but then i really developed my own style
too i've i've followed years of that
though yeah where is why you where
you're at but it was such a natural
thing because i was already doing
mixtape covers and party flyers
so i was like oh crazy you're literally
trying to get a record you're going no
no no
there's money in this
because
i got with i got with dr dre's son
curtis he became my [ __ ] best friend
when i first moved here
i realized that snoop dogg had some sort
of studio right by where i lived as soon
as i realized that
i booked a session down there
got down there i mean it wasn't snoop
dogg's studio it was like some off-brand
[ __ ] [ __ ] where he was probably one
time but it was nice but it was sketchy
as [ __ ]
in terms of just the dude that ran it
and uh
like
i told him i wanted to book a session i
went and met with him and there was some
big la rappers in there when i went in
and the dude big time me the whole time
i sat in this [ __ ] studio for
probably seven eight hours
listening to whatever they were doing
the dudes in his office that i'm
supposed to meet with i just sat there
the whole [ __ ] day
and at the end of the day he like
called me into his office and [ __ ] i'm
getting to know the engineer i'm making
i'm getting to know the people in there
we're hanging out it's not like i'm just
you know but then he like hits me with
some what's your budget type of [ __ ] all
this [ __ ] whatever
i already knew treyson curtis was like
affiliated with that studio because i
saw a magazine cover
so
and i had been on a mission to get a
record deal with dr dre the whole time
so then like i booked a session i had to
borrow money to do it because booking
sessions cost thousands
and then i went in
did my first session and he's like all
right i'm gonna have curtis come into
your next session i don't even ask him
i think he's told jason yeah so then i
booked a second session and i come back
in we're recording and then curtis walks
in he looks just like dre
just like him
it's creepy and i'm recording and i i
see him i just keep going and then
eventually he pulls me out and we sit
there and the three of us talk
and then
like me and curtis started our own
relationship i started recording like at
his house in his closet
which was crazy because he had pictures
of tupac and snoop and
trade show all your idols
it was really surreal doing that that
whole run when we were doing that
together
but that was also the same time when the
[ __ ] with brendan and brian fighter and
the kid all started and i realized like
even though this isn't what i had
originally set out for this is actual
opportunity
i've never made a dollar off music i've
put my all into it i'm just going to put
it on hold right now because drastic
graphics is what's going to keep us
is what i could tell in my heart like
that's what i need to do yeah so even
though i had like basically reached
where i was really i mean on some levels
like really [ __ ] close to where i was
trying to be in music
i abruptly stopped it
abruptly like i was just listening to
the last track i did in [ __ ] curtis's
closet yesterday
uh
went full-fledged into drastic graphics
mode once i had the opportunity with
fighter and the kid
yeah they [ __ ] up not having you tell
your story on their show when you first
started
what a story dude it truly is crazy as
[ __ ] because when you go
2014 and up whoa you've been doing all
this [ __ ] but yeah what about before but
wait what the [ __ ] did just say you used
to do what
yes you rapping because whenever you
sent me i'm like
i really hope marty's music isn't dog
[ __ ] cause when he told him like yeah
send it to me it's like after knowing me
for so long like wait no this is party
because i can hear like oh it's been on
the radio 2000 what
radio i totally hear it
and it's just you know when you're like
oh please don't be dog [ __ ] yeah of
course i don't want i don't want to look
at you like it was cool
yeah yeah
but i was like oh no i can hear it and i
can hear that it's you like no [ __ ]
way just for you to just stop that just
to do drastic graphics it's just such as
like so much even like it's like an
athlete like i'm done playing sports
right when he's about to [ __ ] like i
got signed i don't want to play no more
i was so sick of it
in a lot of ways too i [ __ ] there's
so much
you are literally the blueprint for so
many people out there that watches that
do music like yo if i could if i did
that oh my god come up like that and
then you had it went it was a constant
it was this web i had been weaving for
years if i do this then i can get this
if i do this then i can get you have to
go through people's relationships and
just like
it's this whole and then but i mean i'm
putting out mixtapes also you're white
i'm gonna say this is one of the only
times you're like
might not help you in this in this
situation no it was not an advantage
whatsoever at that time whatsoever
this is
eminem's the biggest one if you're not
eminem then you're probably not going to
make it
because you're looked at is like oh so
what's up eminem subscribe shady there
was i guess they called you that
anyone called you that oh you rap you're
white you watch a mile before they
probably thought that i know i am just
saying yeah yeah yeah it must have been
harder to at that time period of that
just of that yeah yeah because that
music that was coming out was
like 50 cent gu in the show but that was
my saying it was almost an advantage
though because eminem was on some shock
value [ __ ]
when people heard me they didn't know it
was me
like even when i was i i earned i mean
it sounds douchey to say i earned the
respect of the [ __ ] streets and where
i'm from no doubt about it well you're
there also like that you live there from
there even but furthermore but even i
moved around so much i'm not from any
one so when i actually when i was like
like in lackawanna i moved there as a
[ __ ] 16 year old and got
deep respect to the i knew it like at
one point i remember i'm with my boy and
i was driving he was in the passenger
seat this old man were at the gas
station and he starts talking to my boy
in the seat who's huge she probably
couldn't even see me driving he's like i
heard about your boy white boy it's
tough as nails nice and i was like
they know screwdriver [ __ ] know
yeah got that screw in my hand there's
little moments like that where i was
like i knew there were so many little
moments of like it felt really good good
don't try to beat me up those were my
only wins in music those little moral
victories oh man i heard that white boy
stuff his nails
he smacked the [ __ ]
yo i love it
i just remember this one i was like
bunch of little moral victories on the
way but you know that was about it but
like no money in no money couldn't have
helped though
it couldn't have helped like look at
this kid
no
that's how
i mean
when it comes to the like the hip-hop
[ __ ] yeah for sure i think it'd be like
nah full but now it's i think it's it's
different now difference like yo
the stickiest [ __ ] might be the
hardest rapper ever i also wasn't aware
of it i was uh benny i was listening to
benny's new album he has a line on it
where he signs when i was broke my
confidence was on a million then he says
a million
that's how i was like my confidence was
so high it never even crossed my mind
i was it wouldn't have never dawned on
me like this [ __ ] might be
thinking i'm [ __ ] something oh no i
would never think about it i don't care
even like even you're saying it now like
i'm saying it wouldn't helped no for
sure saying it's not like you had the
one time in life we're like i'm six two
blue eyed white man able-bodied i'm
smart that's not my advantage nothing is
helping me in any other situation in
life you're the manager
you are the manager okay
do you see that i see where you're going
no formal education
you're a manager now uh-huh you're fine
that's all i meant that's hilarious
that's [ __ ] awesome it's really
[ __ ] funny dude um
where the hell were we at
you just stopped doing music
you completely stopped the [ __ ] yeah as
you're with uh curtis
you're trying to get the deal with dr
dre you're like you know what i'm
[ __ ] done with it
yeah and then i just dedicated myself to
the [ __ ] podcast how weird is that
yeah it's really weird because like look
back like it would not i want to rap
about that
i'm gonna freestyle right you ever like
do you ever sit there and go music
you never think i have it's i still have
the same
it's still the same to me i don't miss
it because it's all the same
like muscle to me
no matter what kind of like creative
project i'm going into if i'm writing a
song if i'm making a video if i'm making
a cover art if i'm like i get the same
juice from it
got you so it's not like you miss it i
don't miss i've never missed going and
recording really i mean
because it's not me anymore
i get that you don't miss
i've never saw i thought you would think
i would but i really haven't i don't
like sit i'll write songs i don't it's
just a different chapter in my life like
it's like that's like a little time
capsule in my life mind you i could go
back and do it tomorrow if i wanted to
it's just something i could i know i
could like i listen to griselda like
that i could be doing that right now if
i wanted to but it's just not i just i
i'm uh i'm beyond i'm not beyond that
but it's just you're referencing zelda
because buffalo right yeah okay like
yeah these [ __ ] are killing
everybody yeah that's what i'm saying
like
i could be doing i could that could be
my path but my god i knew like this is
this feels right to me that's what i
want to be doing yeah no i'm just saying
yeah you know you ever talk to boxers
but you don't miss it but yeah i almost
punched somebody every day
it was like every day when we talked
about when i stopped playing basketball
it was real abrupt i got yeah i crashed
and burned and then i was
dead like obsessed with music
i never thought about basketball again
i was obsessed with basketball my whole
life up until that point
crashed burned switched obsessions
okay
i a hundred percent understand what
you're saying because i all i did was
play sports i was a kid and as soon as i
stopped i didn't give a [ __ ]
but i do sometimes because it's fun
but i i totally understand i didn't like
the feeling of being out here and like
still being half of the dude i was in
buffalo
i didn't like it i was going like i
didn't want to be him anymore
i wanted to be a young successful like
entrepreneur like all these other people
in irvine that like especially when we
moved into the park
which is like luxury brand new
apartments we got a deal because april
worked for the company when we first
moved here it looks it's straight up
luxury and i felt like straight white
trash when we moved in i was
self-conscious like i didn't want to be
who i was i wanted to
i wanted to be more i went i was
not saying like that's childish or
anything you just don't want to be that
guy anymore past chapter of my life it
was like a rebirth moving here just a
different life i didn't want that's fine
yeah like all i was talking about in
jail going i'm gonna do good my music
was about struggle i wasn't i mean my
music was about making it out that was
if you look back on my music that's what
it's all about the first couple years
were on some like street [ __ ] but then
when you look beyond that to when i was
really going in making real music like
it was all about making it out basically
like what my goals were and [ __ ]
california campaign
it was the only way that i could see
that i could get out yeah
like make something cool happen in life
first it was like all right i gotta go
to the nba i was like all right i need a
million dollar record deal like i've
i've always liked those like
every [ __ ] one in a million pounds
well i know the other day you go we need
a million-dollar sponsorship yeah you
said that to me like three days ago i
say it very million dollar sponsorship
man yeah we're having conversations i'm
like yeah yeah these are all cool but
let's not [ __ ] forget like
let's start thinking about some goddamn
million dollar deals and i say that
because i mean people have done it yeah
that's not a bad way to think man if
anybody's done it we can do it i've seen
it be done you know by people before
meaning it can be done
and the thing i like about it is i like
as soon as this camera's off and [ __ ]
it's not like anything changed and it's
more like yo if i gave you a million
dollars more what do you do with it i'm
gonna go pay this off i'm gonna do this
i'm gonna do this this this like cool
me too
you know what i mean like it's not you'd
never even [ __ ] know
what you never even got a million
dollars i know what you're saying
you might know i got a million dollars
because i'm like yo this car i wanted my
whole life i got it like wow got a
million dollars you [ __ ]
i'm not saying i'm gonna go like yeah
because the million dollars is really
not a lot of money
at all but i'm saying at once here's a
million dollar deal like wow
thank you that's breathing room
especially when you're like so broke
when you were trying when you were
trying to do stuff so broke it's like
holy [ __ ] that's why i always feel like
if i'm watching our show i always forget
it's us i'm always just watching a show
when i'm watching my homies music videos
i'm not looking at my homie i'm looking
at like all right who's this artist yeah
subjectively
every time because i wanna i wanna be
honest
i [ __ ] like when ratchet showed me a
[ __ ] i didn't like so this is all more
[ __ ] i know i was like
could this be on radio spanish radio all
[ __ ] day would i see this on mtv
latin or whatever the [ __ ] it is him
specifically for sure
him i go okay so he's like a rocker dude
uh
he sounds like that
holy [ __ ]
i love the contrast yeah he'll he'll be
popping
i like looking at people like that
so when i watch our [ __ ] i'm not looking
at oh i didn't like the way i move oh i
don't like the notes like
i think i said something funny right now
like oh
oh that do the hat and that was
hilarious i think of it as if i'm
watching it as some dude in missouri
some dude in kansas when i watch this
show if i was just sitting there smoking
with my friends
yeah
i'd watch it
that's how i hope
it comes across because i got a lot of
sure my dad watched the show now i
showed it to my mom my are watching the
show
we watch it with our daughter our
daughter watches almost every episode
it's crazy which is i did not expect
that to happen because you literally
told me i don't know if i show her
bullet fiction yeah that wasn't told me
that four months ago yeah
all bets are out the [ __ ] window
sorry for saying [ __ ] so much now
but it's cool i mean when i think back
to when i was 12 i mean
i was listening to [ __ ] tupac deep
yeah you know which is fine but which
isn't different you're fine it's just as
a dad and you know you edited it when
you should go hey earmuffs don't listen
to this
yo hey maybe you should just go get some
water real quick and come back when i
tell you yeah it's been a couple times
yeah uh
go that way
so we have been talking for almost two
hours right we got we did a
chronological thing right now i should
have rolled way more wheat we got a
chronological thing going on right now
right hold on hold on i don't mean to
interrupt you but i do what i got
something here for you
one of them
what are you doing well it's almost your
birthday oh
you scared me i thought you were gonna
pull out some no i'm gonna i'm gonna
overlay this on the screen but somebody
sent me a birthday video for you a
birthday video uh-huh
[Music]
well so i'm not the only one around here
with a nickname huh
i like yours i don't understand it but i
like it
martin o'neill has been talking to me
and he said it's my best friend thomas
aka dope as yola's birthday that's crazy
right
die hard seinfeld fan get the [ __ ] out
[Laughter]
well very good very good indeed i think
that makes you a little soup worthy
you should have some soup on your
birthday so
the ordering procedure is crazy have
your money ready speak your soup in a
loud clear voice order and step six feet
to the left this [ __ ] is with
the times what are you
unless of course
dopasiola
you're
pushing your luck little man in which
case as you know it would be bread
three dollars no soup for you come back
one year
next
yo this man i think you want that
youtube or podcast that kind of an
outcome won't let everyone know you got
your soup so
get your soup
have a happy birthday
and
adios
yo
no
way
that's just crazy right
the second i can't say that the [ __ ]
soup nonsense what do you say
it says cameo
no
you're the man
so funny right oh my god my homie you
still next door to him i almost got so
sad i was like you better snoopy i see
[ __ ] oh
holy [ __ ]
i did not expect that yeah i was like yo
what are you going to show me
awesome thank you so much yeah
thank you for the sick bills heady
i'll flash it up on the screen
bro what
it's borderline this episode's right in
between both our birthdays and and
freeway rick ross pushed us back so it
was kind of nice
that was [ __ ]
awesome
this episode's coming out on my birthday
yeah yeah
hey
yo soup nazi
that was so [ __ ] epic please send me
that after we're done yeah yeah
uh
i can i'm where was i going i
i was saying something it sounded like
you had uh some path you wanted to go
down that i didn't know about or some
[ __ ] sorry interrupted
what happened
sorry we were talking about everything
and then you that that threw me the [ __ ]
off yeah yeah yeah
and i said man i wish i would have
spoken yeah no so we basically just got
through
uh
we basically just got through like where
are you at getting all that educating
myself through the camera buying all my
equipment i bought all my ten thousand
dollars worth of equipment i did two
shoots hold on huh
soup nazi
all right
out there sorry
i'm still
processing i went to senator
got to put him on the sideboard now
right oh
[ __ ]
okay
you got all your stuff
you did your shoes with the uh did
everything we started you started liking
video more we met me that's 20 20. yeah
so i go to i go back to buffalo for the
first time win
win i knew you no so i went back to
buffalo in late 2018
and you left in 14.
13 13. yeah 13. july 2013.
you know it was really trippy we got a
three-month airbnb with my boy from
buffalo that i did music with mikey
when we got to the house across the
street from the airbnb house this
big-ass house in tustin was this little
basketball court that belonged to one of
the neighbors it was a little dirt
private road and they said we could play
on it
etched in the concrete of this
basketball court it's on martin and
michael
both of our names whoa
[ __ ] trippy whoa but then that was it
oh that was the whole story oh that was
like nothing else on the concrete
but yeah anyway he he headed back to
buffalo like right away um you guys got
an airbnb here i know you guys seen the
story before but marty was with the guy
curtis dr dre son they happened to come
to a party we needed a camera guy marty
said i'll do the camera guy and he was
filming that was [ __ ] me right after
that time frame i'd only been here about
a year
so then wild now okay so i go back to
buffalo for the first time i see my
family i was telling you about i
reconnected with my mom's side of the
family at a family reunion for the first
time ever
which was a huge you met them
like
yeah re-met a lot of my family which was
like a really big moment i was at
delaware park which
you know like we were talking about
r.i.p man that's [ __ ] there's a
horrible news we're talking about
delaware park and buffalo last episode
horrible tragic news story happened at
delaware park since then like two nights
ago
anyway i was just looking at the
pictures we were there
but then while we were there like i
listened to whatever dopaziola video was
that you said you wanted to do the
podcast and i reconnected while i was in
buffalo oh so really yeah because i
remember when you gave me the dm a nice
and i'm like
let me see what this guy's got to say
for some reason like let me see what
this guy's got and like april didn't
know what the [ __ ] you were i was like
trust me this could be something big i
just made a big connection as soon as we
get back i'm gonna go meet with him as
soon as we came i was there for like
[ __ ] three weeks it was so exciting
oh my god so this one is the first thing
you've been back did you see anybody
that we've talked about
yes yeah yeah i saw
i saw a couple of my boys
mm-hmm and what were they doing same
[ __ ]
yeah well like two of my boys that i'm
talking about are real are like real
active in music still my boy weedy and
my boy adot they still they're on it
like to really
still do it good [ __ ] so it's like yeah
they are still they're still doing music
um so yeah i mean i connected with them
and then like they had like did they
trip out when you're not doing music no
more no
surprisingly no nobody [ __ ] nobody
has said anything nobody it was like
very natural i mean just because i'm
just i had i was drastic graphics the
whole time too
they weren't they were going alongside
each other supporting each other the
whole time so i was like i'm just you
know i'll get back to it if it presents
me opportunity but until then i'm just
going with i can't yeah keep just
dumping money into music that's selfish
and i i don't see myself going out into
la and performing i never even like
performing like i like recording i like
going and making albums and putting
together albums yeah that was my thing
and all the behind the scenes [ __ ] that
i do for this i really like making all
those connections
making [ __ ] happen like that's what i
really like doing yeah you know but
so uh
then i came back and then i met you i we
came up met with you i was like damn i
felt like i knew this dude for a [ __ ]
long time we just sat and talked and
uh like right away i had already been
knowing who you were and [ __ ] i've been
watching your video i've been following
you since i had originally met you so i
already knew what i was getting into and
i didn't even know i met you yeah i
didn't know you were you were in my
video until my mom episode yeah so it
was like i didn't even know all that
preparation i thought i was going to be
following these fools around on the road
having to travel
learning how to do all this [ __ ] but it
was like
all that preparation was for we just
like took the dopeziola channel up the
whole year yeah right away like
with the story times with the vlogs with
everything
and then
started planning this we were planning
this
month one
yeah
well you i knew i needed i wanted to hit
you back up because you said i've been
following you for a long time but when i
saw that you wanted to do a podcast i
knew to hit you up yeah i'm like okay
good because most people are like let's
work what the [ __ ] does that mean i
can't stand when people say let's work
like what do you do [ __ ] i do
multiple things be specific that just
means you're
mass dm and [ __ ] let's work
do that [ __ ] to me yeah [ __ ] hate it
yeah because it shows me that you're not
ready you're just wasting my damn time
and that's why i put out the book
because it's like in a situation like
that that's me looking ahead in the
future and knowing i'm going to be in a
situation where i contact somebody i
want to work with and they look me up
this [ __ ] wrote a book i didn't
even look you up
i saw i when you said that sentence i go
i'm going to look into this i'm going to
look at your page and sure because you
know i go through all my dm's when i saw
and i saw a lot of people ask me to work
and i look at their stuff i'm like oh
man
that's not what even what you do
it's not what you do i need something
that that this is their profession if
i'm going to do a podcast i could have
done my guest five years ago
shitty and like my apartment see i
always thought like damn i'm working
with big name comedians i'm gonna start
i'm gonna get my money working for
famous comedians like eventually i would
if i work hard enough like eventually
this is this only makes sense but it
that whole chapter of my career was
building up credentials
and it's more to get to the point to now
where it's like oh i can be an executive
producer of a show yeah
and i had the when i reached out to you
and when i like came into contact with
penne films i have the credentials they
some other [ __ ] works for that's how
they introduced me you're like this
[ __ ] works for x y and z
and then now they have a different level
of respect dealing with me you know it's
like because it's not like it's not oh
you you must be [ __ ] awesome it's not
it's like no those people trust you
exactly because i'm not gonna just trust
a guy to say that's who works for me
[ __ ] no yeah hell no
because people might do some weird [ __ ]
and that's on you yeah especially like
joe rogan oh who's marty
i don't know marty but no
you do work you work there they know who
you you're their guy it's i hate when
people just try to slightly name drop
stuff because it just shows me like ah
yeah are you serious cause i don't like
when you do that because people try to
keep it under wraps your [ __ ] 30
favors getting asked yes like no i
really work with that i'm trying to yeah
i know
i'm stepping my boundary with them
because you that's like a chasm so many
people have to try to figure out it's
not easy to deal with there's a fine
line between i'm getting my name out
there i'm working with big people and
i'm getting paid i'm getting taken
advantage of a little bit for my like
where's my hourly rate at and all this
versus what is this going to lead to in
the future and you're just building
blocks though yeah plant seeds of course
but the way you did it was five years
non-stop which is your way it has to be
if you're serious yeah [ __ ] seven
years nonstop no getting paid yeah
if you're serious you'll keep going it's
not there's nothing you're serious i
just knew it'd lead to something bigger
yeah it can't all be like it's like i'm
on to something yes i'm on something i
made people go hey man thanks that was
fun
what did you say yeah
stop
all right i'ma do it again
like that's all it was for me like what
did you say you'd love that movie too
i'll be back tomorrow yeah let me do
another thing and i just kept going and
then
i started talking then when we met
i don't ever talk on camera this long
until i started doing story time so when
he was like let's do a podcast
i think i'm ready i think i'm ready to
start and even when we started
i look back on those videos i'm like ah
i just watched back the first few
moments of our first ever trial run
video we should put it out at the end of
that season oh the first it's really
funny yeah it's it's it's because you
it's like
those first moments you were like
okay [ __ ] we're doing it all right
i can't [ __ ] up right because it's all
like one straight [ __ ] but then after
like one or two little takes you just
found your groove and yeah cause i
remember the first one i'm like can i do
the intro like 70 more times because i
[ __ ] hate it because i do my intros i
i posted once a day on the dobasil
channel
i'm like this like hey so back to the
ninth grade i did that
so back in the tenth grade i did this
because i remembered wait no [ __ ] you
were that that's 10th grade when you met
her
scratch but i'm trying to
it's weird it's weird because i feel
like one day
we could be doing the
so the jimmy kimmel thing then late
night so what's up guys
yeah i feel like i could do that because
i could oh close leachman you're old as
[ __ ] i could talk to clarissa she's
[ __ ] awesome oh
logan paul what's up man let's talk i
feel like i have that first 12 to 90 age
range pretty locked in buddy yeah like i
couldn't associate and talk i knew
carolyn was gonna be like what the [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] funny i love that guy he's
very you were astonishing him with all
your references that's because he's not
used to it man most people seem like how
old are you 20 23 like
even if i was 23 milford still all the
same [ __ ] it's just how are you brought
up yeah like the [ __ ] that you like
and i don't know i feel like we could do
a late night show i feel like we could
do a talk show uh mario lopez whenever
you're ready to be like hey man
i know i'm buff but thomas you can take
over my spot like i'll take over mario
lopez bye i'm trying to get buff right
now how about this world if i get
buffered tomorrow lopez put me on jimmy
kimmel late night joe because that means
i've been working my ass cause that full
is ripped and he's like
60. i know he's probably not 16. he's
like early 80s
[ __ ] wrestling and [ __ ] what was
it say by the bell when they wrestled in
like the hallway
it was so odd like oh you guys are on a
set
couldn't just
make it look like a gym
in the middle of the hallway
they did that in power rangers too
i'm sorry i'm starting to reference a
bunch of dumb [ __ ] power rangers jason
red
220 221 yeah right [ __ ] wrapped at 220.
sorry marty i'm just going on top
um ready
let's do it
i
have this is the path i was going to
take we got you chronologically all the
way up to this point so for everyone out
there
marty
they always ask you should uh have marty
sit at the table here we are you've
heard from
birth
to now right pretty much
so i want to get into like the
in-betweens
you were doing some wild-ass [ __ ] as a
kid too
because you told me some stories
all right for everyone out there while
we're getting set up marty is way more
aggressive
telling stories outside of the camera
than he is on camera
so
why why are you carrying around a fake
gun
to scare
okay all right are you talking what we
were talking about earlier
yeah i'm talking about we're talking
about earlier man that's exactly what
i'm talking about
no we had a me and jamal had a stretch
where we'd go to the um
to the flea market and get bb guns and
then paint them all black
and have a monos
just to [ __ ] around with basically
but they definitely look like real guns
and his bank robbery was shortly after
that and at first i was like he did use
a real gun but it was in this little
stretch of us [ __ ] with all these bb
guns
and uh and like i said
there was
i keep saying like i said because we
[ __ ] talked about this earlier yeah
but he was doing [ __ ] with the bb guns
that
foreshadowed him doing crazy [ __ ] with
real guns
uh just on some
terrorizing innocent people thing yeah
and we're not trying to sit here and
just put this guy down we're just
talking about stories you guys just [ __ ]
yeah no this yeah i mean we i mean the
bb guns weren't really a huge deal the
one little incident he scared this girl
with one that you know uh
and but then there wasn't like we were
talking about we're there's this whole
situation and we're in the backseat of
this girl's car and this full we're at a
red light and this kid rolls
rolls down the window there's a father
and son next to us points the bb gun at
him and like the fear in this dad's eyes
like in his son in the front seat young
kid now especially that i look back at
that i've always remembered that because
that was one of the moments i i was like
oh we're different that was one of the
moments i realized i would never do some
[ __ ] like that we're different bro
you're
some darkness inside there
and there
i mean
you know i hope all the best for the guy
yeah i mean i don't i don't know you
know i don't i don't i had to really
because like i said after everything
that happened i was really mad for a
couple years but then i just as my son
got older i looked and i look at how
like vulnerable he is how sensitive he
is
and just like i could never imagine a
little kid going through what he went
through and that's why you're like okay
i understand doomed he could never have
normal
relationships or normal life
i mean he like
you know he heard from his mom from the
first time
ever while he was in jail
like on the back of a napkin type [ __ ]
because he was bumping into his
biologicals in prison whoa
and like he fought yeah i mean he found
out like there was a whole crazy saga of
finding out where you come from while
you're in prison
yeah what a place to find out yeah hey
here's a napkin from your mom basically
what the [ __ ] did you get this yeah that
would be the first thing i asked like yo
could you stick some cool [ __ ] in if
you're gonna sneak in this no that'd be
my first thing to ask
i mean it's always i mean imagine you
don't you know you don't know who your
parents are and then you you might not
want to find out oh yeah or the scenario
behind
you know
everything
crazy [ __ ] so i came i definitely came
to a place where i don't walk around mad
about this [ __ ] anymore i mean that
feels like a past life all that like i
don't i also think that type of [ __ ]
gives you cancer like yeah the negative
[ __ ]
holding big long having conversa right
now i bet you you guys just want a lot
of you just stopped having this
conversation 10 minutes ago where you're
having a full-on argument with a person
that's not even there about a situation
that happened five years ago
i've done that yeah i still do it but
it can consume you at the same time yeah
you got to stop i have full-on
conversation with people that [ __ ] me
and i go like just fools that played the
[ __ ] out of me when i thought they were
my friends yeah
and i just like
it literally physically hurts my head
thinking about you can have stretches of
weeks where something really bothers you
months or years yes that's why i can't
that's why i always say i'm so glad i
wasn't a gangbanger i'd be dead because
i can't let nothing crazy [ __ ] go like
that like what'd you do
what'd he do
oh i'm never going away
thinking about it so don't do that for
everyone out there you had to let it go
because it's going to kill you
eventually thinking about it yeah and
you know
i understood i just grew up
more and just like you know people go
through crazy [ __ ] in their lives or
whatever i don't know but
my circle's so tight at this point that
you know it really doesn't [ __ ]
matter
yeah nor and it was good for me to be
completely isolated because i didn't
still have one foot in buffalo for i
didn't go back for five six years it's
crazy so
i was completely isolated and i just
made like you know a whole new life out
here and when i did go back to buffalo
and saw my boys it was [ __ ] amazing
like when we went out to dinner and that
was really cool like you know we were
out at a bar and [ __ ] and
came through but then also i was like
went back to the hood for a little bit
we were chilling and [ __ ] and like
seeing some of my peripheral boys that i
might not have expected to see and them
come through like
telling the younger dudes there about
like uh
you know this motherfucker's a legend
right here like this [ __ ] he went
through all the [ __ ] like really like
they're on some music shits though he's
putting in context what the [ __ ] you
gotta do to make it happen type of [ __ ]
like a coach like a like a coach that
really cared about you would like yeah
[ __ ] shout some [ __ ] at you
that's what he was doing yeah and that
felt really cool just to sit there and
be like damn i'm on the opposite side of
this one i don't even care about that no
more which is crazy too
that is crazy too that's why last time i
was in those apartments was
we were on it was our life mission i
mean it's my whole identity
my whole life like i'm like that i guess
yeah the videos you've sent me
of you filming your homies yeah yeah
these houses because it's cool because
we were going to make a dvd we were
going to like put out a dvd at some
point and i got all this [ __ ] hood
footage you and that beard and all the
chin [ __ ] chin strap you had all that
crazy beard it just like well that white
dude's got a pistol
that's all i look at well that guy
stands with a
he's got a pistol right there
i could see it like a damn
you're the only white [ __ ]
yo that's cause when i went to oregon
like
damn brown [ __ ] i'm the only brown
[ __ ] here when i went to my
school i wait
whoa
i don't feel safe i guess and i know
that sounds terrible but it's more like
did i come to a good town or a racist
yeah what kind of white town what kind
of white town is this but the same with
the uh you go to like a predominantly
asian town of yo are these like the cool
old asian chill like water and plants or
are these the fools with oozies because
there's always though that's why i say
people think of mexicans oh i went to
east l.a and it was fine like yeah not
all mexicans or gangsters are stupid but
it's what you have to assume like so
which
part of town yeah yeah
you can always tell when it's a when you
ever see a 99 cent store you know you're
you're getting to the oozies
there's never a 99 cent store where
there's
targets
you're going to stay on that like right
next to
[ __ ] this
store right next there's 99 percent
there's 99 cent stores next to the
dollar generals every [ __ ] within a
three mile radius yeah there's a check
into cash
check and goes a lot of those you're
like uh
roll them up like if i get national
lampoons but no dude it's uh
it's it's it's different it's funny
seeing the like
damn are you really out you're just
chilling
[ __ ] because because you don't think of
it because i know you as this person so
i'm like
i would never roll around just chilling
with a gun with my homies
no but now it's different i have a lot
of friends i'll have guns and it's like
you guys are all adults and [ __ ] i know
i'm jesus i just got my gun license and
i feel like responsible
yeah you need that what i'm saying when
you were younger it's like yeah you're
crazy you're rolling around with well
you were the future and you're in
i would never put myself in that
position because my mom i'm gonna get my
ass beat
and then go to jail yeah i was always
super scared of jail i never had a fear
of my parents there was never physical
but i was always super super scared of
jail though
you don't want to go
oh i can't leave
yeah
that's my thing like how long do i gotta
be here
i go crazy i go [ __ ] insane at normal
things yeah i can't
and then when jamel went to jail like i
was i was going up there all the time
and i was very i was mentally in there
with him it was like traumatizing like
being a young kid in there and growing
man's jail and i was just like waiting
for him and [ __ ] like i extra knew i'd
like
was aware of it
you know i mean i was going all the
prisons when i was a kid so i was kind
of like i never thought of it like that
all i thought was my only fear growing
up was i hope some dumb [ __ ]
don't shoot me in the face
i was my always thing because i'm i'm
always super cool everyone knows me like
but there's gonna be that one stupid ass
fool what i'm selling a sack to and they
see me selling or something dumb or i
always sold sweet to my friends but like
i always thought ugh
where you from shut the [ __ ] up man dude
do you need to ask me where i'm from
dude
do you hear the way i'm talking to you
yeah like is my geography really do you
see my vans
i'm not affiliated [ __ ] now it
doesn't matter people gangsters wear
vans i get that but
that was my fear of that and yours is
jail like jail never so much because i
saw and go oh i have to get that too
[ __ ]
i have to stab oh [ __ ]
i can't just read a book can i just be
the guy that reads books oh that's nerd
you can just be the nerd
the nerd that helps you guys write stuff
or something but the jail thing all that
i was scared of the randomness i was
scared of like i was always aware of
like damn i could be sitting here a bull
come through the window
i thought about that a lot too like yeah
like randomness like you're playing
basketball like the kid at delaware park
the other night
playing next thing you know you're
[ __ ] dead on the court
because uh you followed the [ __ ]
too hard or something
i talk well i'm good at de-escalating
things very very very good at it because
i always go
you know if this wasn't happening you'd
probably smoke weed
right you smoke weed me too
can we just like talk about this
that's my thing that's so [ __ ] funny
you say that it's true though any time
there's something de-escalated like full
i got a blunt mm-hmm
can we not fight mm-hmm i'm just smoking
seriously wait who's your
you went to what school
yeah and then that's how it always works
out like oh you killed somebody for what
uh-huh who's oh that's his brother at
some you knew that kid you [ __ ] up and
just killed some guy over an argument i
hate it so [ __ ] much that's why i
hate going to stores i hate i hate
talking to [ __ ] grimy fools i
don't like it in public because if i get
pissed and i've punched somebody i'm
gonna get shot
i don't know you know what i'm saying
it's just like
just leave me alone bro i just want to
go to work and come back and i guess i
do my own thing i don't go anywhere and
like i said i'm i'm pretty good at the
escalating [ __ ] like when it comes to
fightings or almost getting shot hey
because people just need to hear that
most people just it's a misunderstanding
percent of the time it's not the boogie
man showing up yeah it's always just a
misunderstanding like what'd you say
like
nothing like some ego [ __ ] it's always a
misunderstanding and y'all you back down
like no
and then you someone get shot
like we were talking about earlier it
just
it's [ __ ] up but since we're on this
[ __ ] topic and i want to
like i said i wanted to brush it
somewhere else
you pulled
an interview with a drug dealer on me
right now and goes yeah you know he
scared that girl with the gun you told
an aggressive ass story in the car
and you told me everything of what
happened
and then here you go why did you scared
it scared a girl with a gun
[ __ ] you told me an elaborate
ass whoa
oh we're about to do a podcast right now
save it
so we'll skip the whole cool part about
this girl was a dumbass and they
wouldn't [ __ ] scare her make her
think she was getting robbed no this
girl was like my borderline half a
girlfriend like i was telling you she
would like oh that's right that's right
she would like literally come by and see
me on the my lunch breaks at the mall
and [ __ ] i was working at the mall and
then hang around and wait because she
was from like
by niagara falls like her she had like a
rich family
she liked coming down and the [ __ ]
lackawanna and [ __ ] so then she like
this one time but she was always so
[ __ ] snakey and sketchy and doing
extra snakey [ __ ] but i didn't give a
[ __ ]
i i really didn't
so
she was would like literally wait for me
in the parking lot of uh
walgreens by my mom's house while i was
working and then she was doing like some
super extra extra [ __ ] or whatever and
jamelle walked up to the car with the
[ __ ] bb gun and like tapped on the
window with the [ __ ] bb gun or some
[ __ ]
scared the [ __ ] out of her while she's
like and then i'm there and then like
dick you know we get in
and then
we're she's like driving us back
i don't think i didn't ask him but we
were like we had it we were like toying
around this is a bb gun
we were like we had it we were kind of
menacing with this [ __ ] thing a
little bit at the time like we were
active with the [ __ ] people sounds
like
[ __ ]
no i mean you're the commercials
don't play don't hang around with don't
play with fake guns yeah the kid gets
shot that was you guys but i mean i had
a real gun too i know
i know but this [ __ ] b we would shoot
each other with the [ __ ] we were
having fun with the [ __ ] bb gun i get
it but he was just teasing her on some
like
she was just so she played up the i'm so
[ __ ] stupid and suburban like that
was her thing you know and then like he
was just she just came wild uh i want to
date a hood guy but not to
marty
she just saw blue eyes yeah that guy
he plays he raps
i'll even wait for you outside the
parking lot i'll wait all day
so yeah but that was when that exact
incident is when the thing happened when
he pointed the bb gun at the the [ __ ]
dead son of a red light because that
moment always stuck with me and then
like i said shortly there after this
[ __ ] was pulling
real robbie's bank robberies yeah [ __ ]
so did he get out of the bank
yeah he was he got out and was robbed
so took off they got off on foot they
ran around the corner now we're in one
of the they're in one of the nicest
suburbs kenmore it's like uh it's robbed
a nice bank they robbed the police
credit union
okay like the whatever kenmore police
credit union
okay
also like
damn that's a bold move for some
17 years 16 year olds no we're not going
to rob the bank we're going to rob the
policeman so when i go to jail
everybody's cheering me
so they went in they did it they had his
car car parked around the corner he had
like almost like your car it looked like
uh almost looked like the training day
car but it was like a buick nice the
wreak was like yeah it was a throwback
and they hopped in that they made a big
scene everybody saw him in the
neighborhood they peeled out and they're
three days later they're still in the
car together
and they got pulled over and they all
went the [ __ ] to prison so if they
didn't roll around that car anymore they
wouldn't have caught them i would they
have mass on i think so yeah bro what
they got away they got away for a couple
days ask them how much money they got
away with
not really i didn't ask specifically i
really didn't i would have been like
because how much did you get he didn't
i don't you know what i never [ __ ]
asked i said hey you should just give me
it to me even while you're gone we
didn't even we didn't even
it was so traumatic for my family we
didn't even talk about the actual act
we didn't even talk about it it's
[ __ ] crazy now that i think we didn't
i never asked them how much money they
took
i don't even know where the money went
you should've asked that you wouldn't he
didn't have any [ __ ] money what
somebody ended up with whatever somebody
got that money there was a bunch of
dudes though that he was with oh really
four dudes went down
oh [ __ ] yeah they were all around the
same
car they just robbed a bank with
yeah they walked into the police credit
union and rob oh my god yeah
savages yeah and i had no idea we saw it
on the news type of [ __ ] my mom called
me i just met april
watching this [ __ ]
yeah like and i was like me and him were
cops chased him away and everything in
the cars or they got him they got out
they
they got away yo the cleanest break ever
they didn't get away that's [ __ ] sad
he was asking for it yeah he's
definitely asking he was on a string he
was going through a lot of [ __ ]
you know he really sounds like he's all
[ __ ] up
like i remember one time we um
they used to have me house my uncle just
had me house set when they would like
go places or whatever once they moved
out into the suburbs and jamal was
living in one of these other foster
homes on the east side
for like time beings and [ __ ] but i
would still go get him we'd still be
[ __ ] hanging out the house i'd be
house sitting
so he's no longer like living with my
and uncle but me or like still [ __ ]
hanging at the house
because i'd go and pick him up and then
or whatever and then like we'd have a we
had a party one time at the house and he
got
real drunk
and he's [ __ ] i mean not only did he
puke all over the sheets that i had to
handle because i was
eating like but then he's like bro my
mom like he started talking about us it
was the first time i ever heard him talk
about
like
yeah all that [ __ ] we never really
talked about it and like that was just
like damn bro yeah that to me is like
i don't know what to do with that level
of pain there's yeah and then i mean
at some point i realized like
all the people in my life all my closest
people in my life had that level of pain
like they all had
like really bad childhoods
and i was i remember thinking like damn
i'm really lucky because when i was
really young like it was dope it was
fine like it was just normal like i
didn't have all this extra [ __ ] going on
they just
was just normal great yeah and i i
realized that we were different because
of that like i know i'm not capable i
would never rob in a [ __ ] bank even
then like
even when the dude was telling even when
the dude said rob the but rob a [ __ ]
bank oh yeah when he asked you but you
get to get back it wasn't enough cards
for me yeah you know like what you know
and it's the same thing that we were
talking about the difference between
you know if you're if you're if you're
if you grow up like uh you know and
you're a good person by your formative
years if not you could be a cold-hearted
kid at 15 [ __ ] shooting [ __ ]
for sure by the time you're 19 you're
cold as [ __ ] yeah
ugh
i know a lot of people if you grow up
with your parents beating you and your
parents treating you like [ __ ] i mean i
s
i saw it a lot
i didn't i didn't have that so i wasn't
completely
i had a killer instinct
i developed that like i remember like
music gave me that
like real confidence
i didn't really have that in basketball
i was the hardest worker and that was
always enough to float me by but i
didn't have a killer instinct if i had a
killer instinct i would have gone way
the [ __ ] further yeah but i was nice
but when i started doing music and
really hanging out
i developed that and that stuck with me
for sure i'm just saying like from all
the entrepreneur people who are doing
graphics people doing music people
trying to come up people trying to work
for
do you see what i'm saying like it's a
blueprint i mean the way i see it that's
why i'm playing who is this guy like
don't worry man he works really [ __ ]
hard that's all that matters yeah truly
like i don't me a lot of people that
have the work ethic like that at all
ever
[ __ ] ever
re if it's not outside of my family i've
met maybe three people like that
i know i know like
people work hard trap and drive and
drive and yeah i get that i get that
but it's the
making money legitimately that was the
hardest thing ever yeah i never yeah i
never
i never like you know i was ever selling
drugs myself i never like
made a bunch of illegal money i never
had any [ __ ] money yeah
i was saying like you had to do it just
literally just working and working yeah
working working like exactly
the unglamorous route yeah which is
[ __ ] awesome yeah
yeah but i mean [ __ ]
worked out
[ __ ] paid off that's what i'm
grateful for now worked out
your house should be done this this
weekend in like two weeks it's going to
be you're moving in this weekend so it's
going to be like
still being worked on while we're living
there for a little bit but you're moving
in this weekend
all the rooms are done the bedrooms yeah
i mean even since i've been here i've
been getting pictures about the [ __ ]
updates to the floors went in and [ __ ]
yeah how cool what a different feeling
it doesn't feel real yet because it's
been just what else in the [ __ ] well
what a good episode then yeah literally
right before you get seriously as it's
good to do this you're gonna move in as
this episode's coming out you'll be
moving in
yeah
with that question
this quick um
it's been two and a half hours yeah
also you're not getting out of here
without telling me the hooker story
yep i want it i want it out
cough it up
the horror story but with you and april
that hooker story this is not going to
be what people expect
april's his wife yeah
go so poker story
the night
could be you told me as we were painting
this wall black oh really i was standing
right there you were standing there and
you were load getting the start and go
and this [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's what we were doing you were
hitting the wall i i remember you told
me the story okay go uh it was the night
mcgregor fought khabib okay
for all our ufc fans out there
so we couldn't find anywhere we got a we
got a hotel at the hotel irvine which is
a really nice hotel in irvine to watch
the hotel because they had it going in
the rest of the fight yeah to watch the
fight they had it going in their
restaurant but we got there and it was
[ __ ] sold out even in the restaurant
at the hotel there's
you couldn't get in
so we ended up going to a random
restaurant and watching it on my phone
which was actually kind of cool i knew
but
it was that or nothing
yeah literally lean on my shoulder
literally it was all right it's fine i
do that [ __ ] with rosie
like would you plan on going somewhere
so then mcgregor got raped and i was
borderline devastated
because you're irish because i was a
huge mcgregor fan up into that point and
what khabib did to him was horrible it
was a decent fight but okabe overpowered
him it was brutal so i started getting
drunk
which i don't like that regular irish
inaudible basically is what he said the
irishman got his ass whoops so i started
drinking we had a hotel night we have a
baby that drives rare yeah three years
ago
probably two okay
we're we got a babysitter we got a night
at the hotel i'm like all right whatever
so i started drinking we we go back to
the hotel and we're sitting outside
april's like smoking a cigarette outside
there's another there's this black girl
outside smoking a cigarette too and they
start talking
and then this girl's probably about the
same age like she looks pretty normal or
whatever and then she kind of very
normal as in like you're not a tweaker
yeah you're not being a creep no she's
just that's powerful you have to explain
to the audience because they're like
what do you mean normal
like no [ __ ] she's not tweaking
somebody you would see at hotel irvine
yeah just a person that's there yeah
regular [ __ ] she doesn't look like
yeah not a tweaker not a creep just a
regular person who's staying there
so then she casually lets it slip like i
forget how she said it but she's like
yeah you know i do i turn tricks or
whatever
i'm down going to san diego hey she just
slid it in like one one wood
like i just mentioned
i got a podcast we record every tuesday
and yeah i had sex
so she kind of slid that out there and
the way she did it we're kind of flowed
with the conversation to the point that
i mean in my mind i'm like okay
but the conversation kind of kept going
but then her friend comes now her friend
does look like a [ __ ] tweaker she's
about the same age but she's a white
girl she got blonde hair she probably
would be pretty if she wasn't a tweaker
and she's acting real [ __ ] weird
like
so now they're talking back and forth
and we realized this whole time april
[ __ ] phase two hmm right she's drunk
i'm getting [ __ ] up but she's
definitely more sober than you yes and
just happens to be yes very much so yeah
april's
social april will talk to people yeah i
would never start a conversation with
you never start a random conversation
with somebody i totally feel you so uh
yeah leave me alone
so we gather that they're going to san
diego to like turn tricks and stuff
[Laughter]
and uh
so this like older white dude comes out
too and he starts like talking to us
we're just still like smoking they're
standing there and you're doing this i'm
sitting there i'm not coming yeah i'm
drinking now yeah exactly i'm not
obliterated [ __ ] face but i'm i'm pretty
[ __ ] drunk
so now this dude starts going off about
how he's a mongol and he's this bad ass
he's like a biker dude i thought this
dude is a [ __ ] accountant by the
looks of him
really and he's telling these girls he's
trying to be a badass in front of these
two girls because he's trying to he's he
smells these two [ __ ] he's trying to
figure out like so he's talking about
how the [ __ ] mongols run this and
that now mind you i know nothing about
biker gangs i know nothing about this
[ __ ] about the bikers yeah with brian
yes it is right it's just a coincidence
so he's talking all this [ __ ] about them
yeah small detail
and meanwhile he's buying him drinks
he's overtly trying to kind of feel them
out he's doing everything but like [ __ ]
give me a quote you know you're like
[ __ ] give me a quote yo that's a good
stamp
comment
[ __ ] give me a quote how much is yes
yeah
so it's kind of funny to me but he is
annoying me at the same time yeah he's
in my space i'm not a part of this i'm
trying to do my own thing here they
probably think
you're running all of them and they
probably thought april was with them too
i don't um and then just maybe yeah yeah
yeah my friends yeah yeah i don't know
so and also now mind you so now he's
talking to us there he's negotiating
with them but but not like he's
negotiating at this point he's
lightly negotia he's negotiating after
he bought him a drink he's like so
what's going to be to go like he's
asking them
and they're like negotiating back with
him whoa yeah
now there's also another just straight
up soccer mom that comes over and sits
with us too
that april like do you want to come sit
with us because like her family was
sleeping or whatever
so a real soccer mom is now in that mix
just she doesn't know what she got
herself into it's it's energy there's
[ __ ] at this point it's
so the two girls start kind of like i
can see like okay these bitters are kind
of crazy they're doing some light
arguing over this dude and he's standing
there still he's going back and forth
he's coming back he's getting drinks
like ultimately they don't end up doing
they don't end up going back to this
dude's room he bought them drinks and
they don't end up going back to this
dude's room now the girl's like i got
some weed up in my room i remember she
said she said i got some wedding cake a
black white chick the black and white
chick she's like let's go get the weed
so me and april we're soccer mom soccer
mom's with us me april and she's my mom
[ __ ] us
she comes with us oh she must be hurting
for [ __ ] fun yes her family went to
sleep she went yeah she's going to go
with these random [ __ ] and couples to
smoke weed yeah she's like following
along now she's cool security's also
aware of these [ __ ] like because i
was going to get drinks i'm talking the
security guard he's like are these two
[ __ ] bothering you back here they're
like no they're fine like he's they were
aware and they weren't staying there
they were
oh but security was aware of these
[ __ ] yeah oh
so we go up to the room
yeah
so we go up to the room to get this
bitch's weed and she's dead oh my god so
me and april and the mom are like
sitting on the couch in the hotel room
and they come in new soccer mom you yes
april yes
i'm pretty much blackout drunk at this
at this point i did have
the mindfulness to record some of this
it's in my photos somewhere i have to i
could it's in my photo so let's find it
and put it on the screen to you and
they've helped you you want me to go to
[ __ ] san diego and help you save you
from your punk ass phones
now you are you
you're a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
right now
because there was a moment where i
recorded some of this yes i'll try to
find it
uh they start arguing the hookers yes
and then the black girl grabs this [ __ ]
by the hair boom boom boom starts
punching this [ __ ] out of nowhere
it builds up i know but you know she's
looking for the weed it happens they're
arguing yeah and then you guys see oh oh
[ __ ] i pull out the phone
i'm bla i'm you have the fight yes
i pulled out where they were fighting
it's recorded a few seconds of it on my
phone uh so she starts beating this
[ __ ] up the white girl is not fighting
back but the black girl is being very
casual about it
like on some
she's talking to her in a certain voice
and then she's [ __ ] punching her and
then she's back to explaining to her in
a stern voice like
it was like that it was kind of weird
weird and the blood the white girl kind
of ate it like there was something wrong
with this [ __ ]
so the white girl kind of like something
wrong with her they're fighting they're
screaming they got somebody in san diego
waiting for him
it's probably not the first time this
[ __ ] has punched this other [ __ ]
me and april are [ __ ] dying at this
point
security ends up coming in so you guys
are dying laughing what soccer mom do
i'm not really aware of what she was
doing but she was there and i was
cracking up with this girl get her ass i
was really really drunk but i knew it
was funny i knew i knew i needed to
record but i knew it was funny you
neighbor were laughing
it was it was just funny how she was
beating her up
so i told you not to fold you like that
yeah basically that's right i'm looking
for the [ __ ] weed yeah and punched
her yeah like she wasn't yelling
they were arguing she was speaking to
her very abruptly and she punched her a
few times
[ __ ]
throw her around a little bit by her
hair she didn't do like ground and pound
[ __ ] the girl wasn't fighting her up and
punching her yeah yeah that's even worse
yeah the girl wasn't fighting back
but she was like
manic so security was like outside the
security ends they're already outside
the door yeah they're already knowing i
don't know why they're like they're like
because they were loud before beating
the [ __ ] out of each other could have
been so you saw the [ __ ] you saw the
yeah that was either little moment of
their little trip you got the breather
outside and they went back to fight
yeah basically probably yeah these
[ __ ] are crazy so now we go back down
in front of the hotel irvine with this
bitch's weed hold on security comes in
says what what was the noise
security didn't make a big deal we're
like we're going out we're going
downstairs something like that i'm i'm
way too drunk to remember exactly what
was said
they didn't like arrest anybody they
didn't break it up they just were there
so she punched a future just one dude he
was probably [ __ ] one of these
[ __ ] to be honest the security guard
got you uh he was lurking around so now
we go back and now we're in front of the
hotel i'm kind of remembering like this
by black scenes
and as soon as the weed came out
i shouldn't have smoked the [ __ ] weed
oh she said wait she beat her ass and
then the security came and he went don't
worry we got the wing we're going
downstairs yes
the white girl i don't think she came
with us you showed me the soccer mom no
i'm talking about the girl that was
getting punched so
not the white hooker so you're with the
black cooker april and the soccer soccer
monster going duck around with the weed
yes oh she's desperate for some fun
okay soccer mom's a white lady uh-huh
even she looks like a straight-up
minivan like love it picture next to
soccer mom in the description
she go downstairs you hit the weed
uh-huh i remember because i was like oh
wedding kick that sounds nice so i'm
smoking this joint soccer mom's talking
to me
i hit the joint and i'm drunk throw up
so now it's like i'm spinning
april's sitting next to me the
security's still back here we're in
front of the hotel securities let you
smoke yes
continue yeah
so we're just chilling
and then i'm talking
puke everywhere
in the front of this hotel
so
yeah
it was the end of the night
they shuffled me up
up into the room i thought i was about
to have some glorious [ __ ] hotel
night with april you know
that's what i expected fast forward to
me driving and having the [ __ ] spins
uh
and nothing happening aside from that
just threw up everywhere
marty you're the only guy ever to be
with his wife
two hookers a soccer mom blunts and
throw up and pass out
i mean probably for the best yeah i was
like nothing else cool could have came
of that situation
if you guys would have hung out with
that girl anymore any longer nah next
next up was like can i live with you
guys
exactly yo i can clean i can do stuff
april don't worry no i just drive me to
san diego let me borrow your debit card
i'm a holistic healer and you have to
take me into
you did not go into that much detail
when you told me i'm so happy i asked
you to say that that's the hooker story
so you so that's the night could be
became my favorite fighter
as well as you saw
black hooker beat up a white hooker it
could be beat up mcgregor mcgregor yeah
an irish hooker an irish hooker yeah
i love this yeah it was a great story
i'm i'm glad i was as [ __ ] up for it
as i was because it added to it if you
weren't you would be like breaking it up
and it would have been more serious yeah
yeah no me puking everywhere at the end
was a nice touch too
nice yeah i usually don't get drunk nor
do i get pukey [ __ ] drunk it's
happened like four times
that was one of them in a super classy
hotel
not that classy the security guard let
me
know
like i mean
lookers are cool i met a lot of cool ass
hookers and i know they were hookers
until like later i don't know
i thought she was just really cool
i mean you're still cool but
super friendly
i meant uh i was with
magic don juan you know that is yeah
i've hung out with him before okay so
you've been with a bunch of hookers
before too with him well i shouldn't say
i've hung out with him before but i've
been around where he's been before okay
so
he's a pimp
and the girls around him i'm assuming
you're hookers
i met the coolest hooker ever
escort lady of the night whatever you
want to call it
ready
we're in a circle we're on hollywood
bowl or on santa monica at the store
we're in the back and we're smoking weed
i didn't know imagine don juan does not
smoke weed in his mouth his mouth
i didn't know that he only smokes it i
didn't know that was exclusive he
promised his mom he would stop smoking
weed when she was dying so he goes okay
he never said nothing about my nose
jesus christ
okay and i only smoke joints
and he only smokes blunts i never heard
the term white boy when it comes to
joints
i pass the joint he goes oh i don't
smoke white boys and i'm wet
oh what a [ __ ] awesome name for a
choice i've never heard that i never
heard that in my life
but i went
oh that's fine and he passed it and i
saw him pass the blunt i saw him hit it
ignosing it
i'm so glad you passed up on my joy i
would have been kind of pissed if you
put that in your nose of course i didn't
know how could you ever i mean if he
does that that's do your thing that's
cool and you're personal yeah that's
cool once well that's why he's probably
he was like nah i'm smoking my yeah so
he was being cool i mean he's like he's
a cool dude could you imagine just hands
it back staring in your eyes not that
everyone in this crew hit it through the
nose too what
oh that's just their thing no i think
they're like nah you guys smoke like
that too the girls at least all these
girls are with him but i was like wait
and i found out later about the like is
that [ __ ] with his nose
so anyway to the hooker we're standing
there and the chick with them was
mad cool as [ __ ] she was hella tight
she wasn't forward but she was cool i
was with rosie we're all me her rosie
talking
and i look at her heels and i go wait
she's like
a little bit taller than me like a 30
year old black chick i was like 24 at
the time she has like a blonde like wig
or some [ __ ] on
and i'm like this [ __ ] looks tight as
[ __ ] she looks like she's dressed for
a nightclub it's four in the afternoon
we're smoking weed at a i'm like you
look like
oh you're oh you're a hooker
oh that's why anyway her shoes had no
heel
so she's like no my leg stays strong
she's standing on heels like a baller
and there's no heel
she's like no it's just like a certain
type of war like it's a thing to keep my
lit i'm like wow you're flexing at all
and then she's like yeah i'm good and
then she like did this ass shake thing
when she dropped to the ground
on her [ __ ] shoes and rosie was like
what the [ __ ] my damn you're strong as
[ __ ] and that was a really cool cool
hooker right there
her name was pepper
get her on soft white on her belly jesus
christ oh she was a cool hook she had
her [ __ ] together she's not a soft white
underdog hooker
she was awesome but that was my little
hooker story and she was cool
but
she was tight and that was
yes bro no heel
the [ __ ] is that it's like interesting
it's like it's almost like being like a
freelance graphic designer like what
level of stock
how much do you charge
like there's a big chasm you guys just
started the sentence
just a circle just guys we're just going
to bring this back
being a jurassic
uh graphic art is kind of like being a
hooker how much do you charge
no it's not at all it's all the service
industry okay the service industry
because you got people out there doing
graphics for 15 all right you got
hookers out there working at that rate
yes and then you got these super high
class ones that are like damn this looks
like a classy
woman but she's super expensive
so there's the peril so
make sure you make a marker and have
your daughter leave the room
right before we start this part of the
conversation when you're watching this
episode yeah she might have missed this
one jesus [ __ ] christ all right yeah
service yeah it's kind of like being a
hooker
stop
um
hooker story
it's a good clip love it you
from
birth
to now yeah that's what we're doing
yeah i love i loved it i did i like i
said i didn't want to ask because either
like eight stories in my head i could
think that you've told her i'm like yo
you gotta tell them the [ __ ] podcast
yeah but i'm gonna leave him i'll leave
him i'll you say leave him want more
yeah exactly even want more we're not
gonna get it all out slow drip kind of a
slow drip
exactly like uh
like for the story times i was like i
wish i didn't throw eight stories per
episode
season one yeah
yeah because it's like you still like ah
let's pace it
that's what we're doing with this like
there's more episodes to come yeah we
got series there's more stuff there's
seasons this is season one so
guys there's more to come [ __ ] yeah um
is there anything else you want to talk
about man i don't think so i think we
kind of we're right where we you know
we're 245 wherever we want to be here
damn yeah 245 the least amount of weed
ever smoked i can't believe
i didn't roll more joints but also good
it helps me remember what i'm talking
about yes also good sometimes i just get
lost
joint but wait
it's not like it's like i lose my memory
because when we talk about this sober i
forget what we talked about it's just so
much conversation at once you forget
so
i'm glad good three joins is enough all
right
um
i think that was it man episode 31 yeah
how are we going to call this episode oh
yeah i don't know
i think
random quotables
yeah slap in the face to god let's let's
call it that like your last quote um
yeah see that would have made a hell of
an episode tied up over like youtube
youtube's really not gonna like that
christian youtube probably won't [ __ ]
with that either
um now we'll stay off topic guys this is
uh
yeah it's crazy it's coming out on my
birthday your birthday just happened
good timing yeah that's a whole nother
episode
yeah that's a whole nother episode we
have
we have a bunch of stuff in the works
guys there's uh there's there's stuff
happening every [ __ ] day
it feels like now we're just looking for
a booking agent
we're just looking for a booking agent
and what else
oh we're moving sets so this oh next
week's the last
episode in the set okay all right
all right we'll talk about it i mean
well maybe two more yeah because we want
to give a week to prep everything yeah
yeah yeah yeah
september is the last time we're in here
it's gonna be october it's gonna be
october for a hundred percent that's
when we're gonna kick off season two i
think right i think so i think we'll
change it to season two yeah yeah i
think we we should change the season two
especially if we're just moving over
yeah it's going to be the same set it's
just
a little different now structure that's
not going to go up way up the sound is
going to go way up we're in a tighter
space it's not dragging extension cords
45 feet to the way more professional for
guests to come in and not just see all
my inventory yeah you know
um
it's a very chill episode man yeah i
feel like we didn't
go crazy no wasn't nothing wow i
appreciate all the fans love like you
know i really do they really show me a
lot of love but yeah that really is like
fuel to the fire like i really do think
about those comments at times when i'm
like
super stressed super tired or even not
that really does keep me going like we
get so many amazing comments i feel bad
that like i can't respond to all of them
but you're way more busy than i am you
can't respond well
you can't respond to all of them with a
meaningful response about how much like
i really appreciate it like if i respond
to you saying i appreciate that fist
bump like i really [ __ ] appreciate
that [ __ ] yeah it's not like a copy i
pace response yeah which you know we're
just i'm getting a lot more messages and
a lot more that's becoming more in my
routine now to interact with the fans
and i love that that's all i have that's
all i want even with music like
yeah it just came a different way yeah
which is so wild yeah that's what you're
striving for except you left it that's a
huge life lesson though because
podcasting didn't even exist i didn't i
could have never said i want to be a
podcaster no it didn't even exist
but you work with what's in front of you
and then when you get there you just
know what's right and you can't be
afraid to let go of who you were for
like
who you wanna be you gotta understand
you're gonna change it's gonna
unfold in chapters you're not gonna
like the same [ __ ] and do the same [ __ ]
you're not supposed to
especially when you're on you're trying
to be an entrepreneur and build your own
business
you know most inspirational podcast
episode of all time [ __ ] all
right this is [ __ ] this is called 12
mile
all right it's called 12 the le the last
leg all right
this is how you're supposed to do it
damn
damn it's it's crazy because when i
think about it that was a whole [ __ ]
movie we went through
just for
the characters in your life and the
things happening i could see it i
totally see it yeah i love it there's a
lot more we could do a lot more of these
i know that's what sally ah this would
probably be about a
nine hour podcast if you really wanted
to go and we could do it but i'm not
going to do that to you guys yeah we'll
sprinkle these in once again yeah we'll
do them once in a while all right this
is the marty o'neal episode or the marty
episode or the way i like to see it is
uh i don't see a lot of producers people
doing camera [ __ ] that have
that do online stuff that you already
did that before you were that so i feel
like it's not like we're a producer it's
like co-host
when we don't have a guest
yeah just that's how i see i don't see
it like
i see you
how do you say it it's
it's not like the talk show host with
conan and andy richters there because
he's there just to talk sometimes he's
not really putting an input we'll have a
whole [ __ ] episode of just yeah
this non-stop it's nice that i can do
that so just kind of switch it up yeah
it's i think when there's a guest here i
like want to let the guests have their
time and like if i'm a part of the cool
if not like it's just whatever happens
happens like yeah i'm saying these are
my favorite ones though yeah yo this is
what we'll do on facetime
all the [ __ ] time yeah it's kind of a
twofer yeah right now it feels like we
we would have done this already anyway
seriously like last night when i was
[ __ ] lifting i'm like
i just have a 50-minute conversation
with marty in the middle of this
holy [ __ ] i forgot yeah because you got
like i said like i didn't have any
friends
when i moved since i moved here yeah
really so i haven't really spoke about
all this [ __ ] to anybody april was there
for the whole thing
ah so you never said it out loud i've
never why would you have a lot of these
times we're talking about this [ __ ] it's
i'm like
what i need you to do i want you to
start writing down one sentence from a
story
and start keeping track but yeah
you know i'm like hey i know what i want
to talk about today yeah
have i think i think you should start
having a story or at least a tie or
something because i like
i like the talk i like seeing the bounce
off and [ __ ]
you know that one just ran out of that
one just a two yeah yeah oh we're good
then okay um
so yeah i think it's i think it's
better i i every single comment is
positive
i mean not no nobody's like oh who's
this [ __ ] dude tomorrow like no it's
awesome it's the other person on the
show it just worked out nicely it's just
i i love it i love the way it goes back
and forth because i always watch
everything as not myself as a person
watching something
oh this guy's awesome it's different
because we have the whole dopey old push
tree [ __ ] going on too so it's like we
split our time a lot
yeah and we're just really immersed with
each other so we know what's going on
like 360. yeah everything it's not a lot
a lot of other situations it's like you
know it's like a job oh yeah that's my
producer
what'd you do this weekend
what'd you do for christmas yeah exactly
maybe what you do for christmas
[ __ ] i was on facetime with your
stupid ass exactly that's how hot it's
like
oh i was there for an hour and a half on
facetime yeah yeah and like when i first
got with fighter and the kid and all
them like i wanted that i wanted i came
from a team mentality with music
i i was all for that also for them
we just need a guy to get this done
there was so much happening it wasn't
time for that yeah it's not a situation
for me to build my clients up and then
it's like now then it's like because
they're in positions that we'll be in
and imagine how busy they're going they
are there as we are right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah i know because we came into
this as business owners a lot of people
come into podcasting as celebrities yeah
the successful ones yes
we're coming we're just as business
owners the first producer to come in
with a full-blown business
already you know what i mean like yeah
people come in as engineers yeah the
people forget like podcasts i love it
takes so much time but also double check
on my other channel chloe all the orders
doing the orders also me and rosie have
to live our life sometime and say hi to
each other i don't want to just be
working all the time and i see rosie at
night type of [ __ ] that's [ __ ] stupid
there's a lot more going on than just
the podcast so that's what
dude i'll forget like yo it's time to
fill the podcast tomorrow oh [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] yeah damn that week went by fast
posting the podcast reminds me that oh
[ __ ] we got a film tomorrow
i like it's like cuz i'm always so
[ __ ] busy until i got the schedule
the schedule i got did you know i have
four days off last week
i didn't film at all
four days
because i did the extra videos that yeah
yeah so i had four days where i was just
like then you got videos on the stash
yep it's never happened yeah i love it
so much
see scheduling myself get yourself
organized and watch your life change for
the better
as soon as i got organized i went oh my
[ __ ] god i'm on a schedule
i love it yeah knowing what i need to
get done and not going oh yeah [ __ ] oh
yeah look i'll get you right now oh [ __ ]
i'm gonna do right now and two weeks
later go oh my god i never [ __ ] sent
him a piece of [ __ ]
yes that's how i've been living my life
my whole life and it's just not good a
little bit of discipline a little bit a
little bit of time it makes to keep and
uphold that thing to be updated so much
the agendas at school were you the kid
that used it
no i i never once [ __ ] used it and i
always go why am i missing all my [ __ ]
yeah well look at that girl over there
vagenza is full she has straight a's
yeah full of notes and dates and
yeah for sure that wasn't me but now it
has to be because you're running all
running all this and running all that
and you're you're already organized as
[ __ ] i need to that's where i'm headed
so it was awesome four days off last
week yes movies twice in a row two days
in a row i went to the movies because i
didn't know what to do with myself yeah
that is right yeah yeah you're talking
about like what i do with off time i
don't have time i didn't know what to do
you got to go live so you can go get
more [ __ ] to talk about
well yeah i guess that too that too i
mean even going and seeing new movies
and [ __ ] like i mean oh man the last two
movies i watched over this [ __ ] so
talk about those next time uh next week
freeway rick ross yes
all right guys the next episode is a
guest episode and we will take it from
there oh yeah anything else you want to
say happy birthday
thank you happy late birthday to marty
just passed
good episode oh
good episode where's your
um yo don't they have their little pads
you can have an extension yeah i could
figure it out i'll figure this out
guys new set coming
sick
[ __ ] yeah i think that's everything oh
yeah good episode
thank you so much for everyone out there
been asking here it is marty at the
table finally got it done finally
figured out how to do it both other
cameras are dead
so you see see we we do have to figure
it out a little more but trial run first
one ever
now we know your life except we don't
know all the pieces in it we just know
the skeleton so at least we know where
you're from yeah where you came from
exactly what was going on
please pop up some [ __ ]
pictures in this edit i want the people
to see the pictures
marty you do not look like marty
i love those pictures if you have to
blur faces blur faces what you eat don't
make me [ __ ] picture makes me laugh i
have it saved
i love it
the jorts the biggest shorts of all time
oh [ __ ] you're from east l.a with those
shorts bro i swear to experience
um you look like you're about to do a
soulja boy dancing on shorts man i love
it i love that's the times that's what
time it was two thousand something 2005.
i get it
um
for the sake of ranting i'm gonna stop
myself it's been three [ __ ] hours
guys this has been marty o'neal episode
this has been the drastic graphics
episode this is
the other half of the show
all right here it is you guys asked for
it it finally got here leave a
[ __ ] comment let us know what
you guys want to see leave a comment let
us know who you want to see
i think that's about it thank you
everything thank you guys so much dope
as usual dot store
uh we're having more numer as you can
see uh the unreleased shirt on marty's
it's puff print so it's really thick
at least push trees hat i see marty have
on the exclusive's going yeah we got
some new [ __ ] marty's
dripping and unreleased business today
guys thank you so much for watching this
has been
another episode of the dope as usual
podcast
from marty and i
have a dope ass day
i'm hot you're about to say something
else it looked like you were about to
say
you were i could see
i'm gonna just stop for next time
yo i don't know how but i got really
high off those joints
right
[Music]
perfect
[Music]